SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. DALLY DODD. THÀNH. RAZO
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LIMÓN
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NILO. OKOBO PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE. WE'LL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN. AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE PLEDGE. ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. LET US GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. WE ARE ALL IN THE SAME
BOAT, AND WE OWE EACH OTHER A
TERRIBLE LOYALTY. G.K.
CHESTERTON. GRACIOUS GOD, IN THE
URGENCY OF OUR WORLD, CONTEXT
BELOW THE VIOLENCE AND
TURBULENCE OF THE WAVES. HELP US
TO MAKE EVIDENT OUR PASSIONATE
COMMITMENT TO ENDING ALL THAT
LEADS TO IMPOVERISHMENT,
MISUNDERSTANDINGS AND JUDGMENTS
OF OTHERS. MAY OUR GROWING
CONSCIOUSNESS OF THE
INTERDEPENDENCE AMONG US AND
WITH ALL CREATION, GALVANIZE US
IN THAT LOYALTY THAT WE OWE TO
EACH OTHER. A LOYALTY OF FAITH
THAT TRUSTS AND TRUSTS OUR FEARS
TO THE GOODNESS OF THOSE WHO
LOVE UNCONDITIONALLY. A LOYALTY
OF HOPE THAT IMPELS US TO WORK
FOR A SUSTAINABLE FUTURE, AND A
LOYALTY OF LOVE THAT ALLOWS US
TO BE FAITHFUL TO EACH OTHER
REGARDLESS OF REAL OR PERCEIVED
DIFFERENCES. FOR WE KNOW THAT
YOUR LOVE EXCLUDES NO ONE. AMEN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
STATES OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO PRIVILEGE OF THE
FLOOR. WE HAVE FIRST UP, SENATOR
LIMÓN. PURPOSE OF INTRODUCTION,
SENATOR LAMONT. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. TODAY WITH ME, I HAVE
MY NIECE AND GODDAUGHTER, EMILY
LIMÓN, WHO IS VISITING FROM
SANTA BARBARA, AND SHE IS DOING
A DAY IN THE LIFE OF A
LEGISLATOR. AND I PICKED THE
BEST WEEK EVER TO BRING HER UP.
SHE WAS IN COMMITTEE YESTERDAY
AND SHE ALSO HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY. SO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO HAVE HER HERE ON
THE FLOOR TODAY. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
AT THIS TIME, WE'RE GOING TO
INTRODUCE THE WIFE OF SENATOR.
NO, SHE'S NOT HERE YET. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
MEMBERS. WE HAVE ONE OTHER ITEM
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
FROM THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
IF WE CAN GIVE OUR ATTENTION TO
SENATOR BRADFORD TO RECOGNIZE
HIS GUEST. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, TODAY,
ONCE AGAIN, I HAVE THE HONOR OF
WELCOMING OUR TO OUR FLOOR. 19
YOUNG AND DYNAMIC AFRICAN
LEADERS WHO ARE PARTICIPATING IN
THE MANDELA WASHINGTON
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM. THE MANDELA
FELLOWSHIP IS A FLAGSHIP PROGRAM
OF THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT'S YOUNG AFRICAN
LEADERS INITIATIVE. IT WAS
CREATED IN 2014 AS AN EFFORT TO
EMPOWER YOUNG PEOPLE THROUGH
ACADEMIC COURSEWORK, LEADERSHIP
TRAINING, AND NETWORKING. SINCE
THAT TIME, NEARLY 6000
OUTSTANDING LEADERS FROM EVERY
COUNTRY OF SUB-SAHARAN AFRICA
HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THE
FELLOWSHIP. DURING THE PROGRAM,
THE FELLOWS ARE HOSTED BY US
COLLEGES OR UNIVERSITIES FOR SIX
WEEK LEADERSHIP INSTITUTES
STUDYING BUSINESS, CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND PUBLIC
MANAGEMENT. AFTER COMPLETING THE
COURSE AT THESE INSTITUTES, THE
FELLOWS CONVENE FOR A SUMMIT
WHERE THEY FORGE CONNECTIONS
WITH ONE ANOTHER AND US LEADERS
FROM PRIVATE PUBLIC AND
NONPROFIT SECTORS, SETTING THE
STAGE FOR LONG TERM ENGAGEMENT
BETWEEN THE UNITED STATES AND
AFRICA. THE SENATE HAS HOSTED
THESE FELLOWS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
IN OUR CHAMBERS AND ORGANIZE
MEETINGS TO ENCOURAGE THEIR
UNDERSTANDING AND ENGAGEMENT
WITH OUR POLITICAL AND
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN CONGRATULATING THIS
SPECIAL GROUP OF FELLOWS ON
THIS, ON THEIR ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
AND LET'S OFFER THEM A WARM
CALIFORNIA SENATE. WELCOME,
WELCOME, WELCOME TO THE FELLOWS.
SENATOR BRADFORD WILL TAKE THE
FIRST PHOTO WITH HIS SPECIAL
GUEST.
OKAY.
BUT NOW IS THE TIME FOR THE
GROUP PHOTO. IF YOU WISH TO
PARTICIPATE. MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE ARE
STARTING THE MAIN SHOW NOW
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE WILL BE
TAKING UP SEVERAL ITEMS. OUT OF
ORDER TODAY. STARTING WITH FILE
ITEM 83, SB 1327 BY SENATOR
GLAZER. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1327 BY SENATOR
FRASER. AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION, THEREFORE, AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
GLAZER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS. MEMBERS
WE ARE IN A MOMENT OF PERIL IN
OUR DEMOCRACY AND OUR HOLLOWED
OUT NEWSROOMS ARE IN THE CENTER
OF THAT CRISIS. LET ME PROVIDE
SOME CONTEXT. DEMOCRACIES ARE
THE EXCEPTION IN HUMAN HISTORY.
IT'S NOT IF THEY WILL FAIL, IT'S
A MATTER OF WHEN THEY WILL FAIL.
OURS IS 248 YEARS YOUNG. 71% OF
THE WORLD'S POPULATION. SENATOR
GLAZER, GIVE ME ONE SECOND HERE,
COLLEAGUES. IT'S GOING TO BE A
LONG DAY. WE CAN GIVE THE
ATTENTION TO EACH PRESENTER.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. 71%
OF THE WORLD'S POPULATION IS
UNDER AUTOCRACIES EVEN NOW IN
COUNTRIES SUCH AS HUNGARY,
ARGENTINA AND TURKEY, WE SEE
THESE DEMOCRACIES TEETERING. HOW
DO WE KNOW THIS? YOU SIMPLY HAVE
TO SEE THEIR ACTIONS TO CURTAIL
OR TAKE CONTROL OF THEIR
INDEPENDENT NEWS MEDIA. THAT WAS
KEEPING THESE DEMOCRACIES HONEST
. THE CANARY AND THE AND THE
DEMOCRACY MIND IS INDEPENDENT
NEWS ON A BILL LIKE THIS. THAT'S
BEFORE YOU TODAY, YOU MIGHT SAY,
WAIT, OUR CONSTITUTION DEFENDS A
FREE PRESS, BUT WE HAVE ALWAYS
HAD A HANDS OFF RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEM. THAT'S SIMPLY NOT
TRUE. EARLY HISTORY IN AMERICA
SHOWS OUR LEADERS ACTIVELY
BACKING AND FINANCIALLY
SUPPORTING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
NEWS. THEY DID IT BY SUBSIDIZING
POSTAL RATES. THANK YOU TO STEVE
WALDMAN OF REBUILD LOCAL NEWS
FOR HIS WRITING ON THIS HISTORY.
THAT VALUE WOULD BE IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS, IF NOT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TODAY. BUT
MOST OF THAT HELP HAS GONE AWAY
TODAY, THE UNITED STATES SPENDS
$3.16 PER CAPITA TO SUPPORT TO
SUPPORT PUBLIC MEDIA. CANADA
SPENDS ABOUT EIGHT TIMES MORE
THAN WE DO JAPAN 17 TIMES MORE,
UNITED KINGDOM 26 TIMES MORE
THAN WE SPEND, AND GERMANY
SPENDS 45 TIMES MORE THAN WE
SPEND PER CAPITA TO SUPPORT
THEIR MEDIA. THESE DEMOCRACIES
KNOW, AND WE KNOW THAT AN
INFORMED CITIZENRY PROTECTS OUR
DEMOCRACY. IT IS WHY DEMOCRACIES
INVEST IN EDUCATION. IT IS WHY
DEMOCRACIES NEED A ROBUST,
INDEPENDENT MEDIA. BUT THE
CONDITION OF THE MEDIA TODAY IS
CRITICALLY BAD. WHY IS THAT? THE
ADVERTISING MODEL THAT HAS
SUSTAINED IT HAS BEEN SEVERELY
COMPROMISED DUE TO THE INGENUITY
OF SOCIAL MEDIA AND SALES
PLATFORMS. THESE ENTERPRISES
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY CONNECTED
FOLKS WITH FRIENDS AND HOBBIES
AND INTERESTS, AS WELL AS
SHOPPING OPPORTUNITIES. AND IN
DOING SO, THESE PLATFORMS HAVE
USED HAVE MINED INTIMATE DATA ON
EACH OF US, ON EACH USER, AND
IT'S ALLOWED THEM TO CREATE AN
ADVERTISING ALTERNATIVE THAT
EFFECTIVELY TARGETS PEOPLE WITH
ADS MUCH MORE EFFECTIVELY THAN
TRADITIONAL MEDIA. AND THE
IMPACT ON OUR NEWS OUTLETS HAS
BEEN SIGNIFICANT. IN THE LAST 25
YEARS, ABOUT A THIRD OF NEWS
OUTLETS HAVE CLOSED NATIONALLY.
NEWS DESERTS EXIST THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. I KNOW WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT YOUR DISTRICT, YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT IN
CALIFORNIA, 65% OF JOURNALISTS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS. NOW, THE
BILL BEFORE YOU IS A RESCUE
EFFORT. IT IMPLIES A MITIGATION
COST ON THE PLATFORMS WHOSE
ACTIVITIES HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS DAMAGE. WE ALREADY IMPOSE
MITIGATION FEES ON COMPANIES
THAT PUT CHEMICALS IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT, OR TO DEVELOPERS
WHOSE PROJECTS IMPACT OUR ROADS
AND OUR SCHOOLS. THE DATA
EXTRACTION MITIGATION FEE IN
THIS BILL IS ASSESSED WHEN TWO
CONDITIONS ARE MET. A COMPANY
HAS ACQUIRED DATA FROM
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
COMPENSATION, AND THEY USE IT TO
SELL ADVERTISING IF THEIR
ADVERTISING REVENUE EXCEEDS 2.5
BILLION TIMES $2.5 BILLION. IN
CALIFORNIA, THE MITIGATION FEE
IS THE SAME AS OUR SALES AND USE
TAX OF 7.25. THE FUNDS ARE THEN
DISTRIBUTED IN A WAY THAT FULLY
FUNDS OUR EDUCATION AND BUDGET
RESERVE OBLIGATIONS, AND THE
BALANCE. THE BALANCE WOULD THEN
BE PROVIDED IN A TAX CREDIT FOR
NEWS OUTLETS BASED ON THE
EMPLOYMENT OF JOURNALISTS AND
NEWS GATHERING WORK IN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, ENHANCEMENTS ARE
PROVIDED TO SMALL COMMUNITY AND
ETHNIC MEDIA OUTLETS, AND
SPECIAL PROJECTS TO SUPPORT AND
ENHANCE THE HIRING AND TRAINING
OF A DIVERSE JOURNALISM
WORKFORCE. MEMBERS. ALL OF THIS
IS DONE IN A CONTENT NEUTRAL
WAY. JUST AS WE HAVE FUNDED A
MOVIE INDUSTRY TAX CREDIT WITH
NO STATE INVOLVEMENT IN CONTENT.
THE SAME GOES FOR THIS
JOURNALISM TAX CREDIT. NOW, EACH
OF US KNOWS THAT HOW ON THE
GROUND REPORTING INFORMS AND
IMPACTS OUR LIVES. THE
LEGISLATIVE ACTION THAT WE ALL
TAKE EACH YEAR IS SO OFTEN IN
RESPONSE TO THE STORIES THAT ARE
DISCOVERED AND WRITTEN ABOUT
THROUGH GOOD JOURNALISM. NOW,
YOU KNOW THE SAYING ABOUT
JOURNALISM. THEIR JOB IS TO
COMFORT THE AFFLICTED AND
AFFLICT THE COMFORTABLE. NOW,
THAT SOMETIMES MEANS THAT WE ARE
NOT ALWAYS IN A FAVORABLE LIGHT.
WHEN STORIES AND EDITORIALS ARE
WRITTEN. WHO HASN'T FELT AT
TIMES THAT ONE STORY OR ANOTHER
WASN'T FAIR OR BALANCED? WHO
HASN'T HAD A TOUGH EDITORIAL
WRITTEN ABOUT THEM? I CERTAINLY
HAVE NUMEROUS TIMES, BUT THE
MATTER BEFORE US, THE FUTURE OF
INDEPENDENT JOURNALISM AND THE
PROTECTION OF OUR DEMOCRACY IS
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE MUST LOOK
BEYOND THE SELFISH HURT THAT WE
SOMETIMES HAVE ENDURED. NOW,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS HAS A BILL
THAT WORKS TO ASSIST IN THE
PRESERVATION OF JOURNALISM IN A
WAY THAT'S DIFFERENT, BUT
COMPATIBLE WITH THIS BILL. OUR
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ADVANCED IT
ON TUESDAY IN THE HOPE THAT SHE
AND I CAN WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS
THIS SUMMER IN BALANCING
EVERYONE'S INTERESTS. THIS BILL
WOULD BE A SENATE VEHICLE TO
JOIN THAT IMPORTANT WORK. JUST A
FEW MONTHS AGO, IN RESPONSE TO
THESE TWO BILLS, THESE POWERFUL
PLATFORMS BEGAN TO CURTAIL LINKS
TO NEWS STORIES. THEIR THREATS
ELEVATED TO SAY THEY WOULD END
CHARITABLE CONTRIBUTIONS TO NEWS
OUTLETS IF THIS BILL BECAME LAW.
EVEN WORSE, ONE OUTLET
PROCLAIMED THAT THEY MAY USE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE TO
CREATE NEWS. SO I ASK YOU,
MEMBERS, SHOULD INFORMATION TO
OUR CITIZENS AND PROTECTION OF
OUR DEMOCRACY BE PUT IN THE
HANDS OF A FEW PLATFORMS? OR
SHOULD WE RESCUE AND CEDE THE
DIVERSE ECOSYSTEM OF INDEPENDENT
NEWS OUTLETS? BIG SMALL PRINT,
DIGITAL BROADCAST, ETHNIC
COMMUNITY, ALL IN A CONTENT
NEUTRAL, OWNERSHIP NEUTRAL WAY?
DEMOCRACIES AND THE PERSONAL
FREEDOMS AND LIBERTIES THEY
PROVIDE. DO NOT LIVE FOREVER.
OUR FOUNDERS PLEDGED THEIR
LIVES, THEIR FORTUNES AND THEIR
SACRED HONOR TO CREATE OURS.
THAT TORCH OF FREEDOM IS NOW IN
IN YOUR HANDS. IT'S VULNERABLE.
IT'S FRAGILE. I HOPE YOU WILL
GIVE ME THE CHANCE TO KEEP
WORKING, TO PROTECT IT, BY
ADVANCING THIS BILL. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SENATOR BLAKESBERG,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, COLLEAGUES. I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB 1327, AND
I WOULD LIKE TO APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR COMING UP WITH A
REASONED APPROACH TO PROTECTING
JOURNALISTS AND JOURNALISM.
JOURNALISM IS FREQUENTLY CALLED
THE FOURTH ESTATE. IT KEEPS AN
EYE AS A WATCHDOG ON GOVERNMENT,
AND IT IS CRITICAL TO OUR
DEMOCRACY. AS A FORMER
JOURNALIST MYSELF, I KNOW THAT
THE STORIES THAT I WOULD WRITE
WOULD HAVE AN EFFECT ON THE ON
THE ENVIRONMENT AROUND ME, ON
THE POLICIES THAT WERE CREATED,
ON THE CONSTITUENTS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WORLD THAT
THEY LIVED IN AS THE AUTHOR JUST
SAID, WE HAVE HAD MORE THAN A
QUARTER OF OUR NEWSROOMS CLOSED
THESE. THIS MEANS THAT THERE ARE
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE NOT BEING
WATCHED BY ANYBODY. WE NEED OUR
JOURNALISTS. WE NEED TO PROTECT
THEM. WE NEED TO PROTECT THEM
FINANCIALLY. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND I URGE
ALL OF YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU. SENATOR PADILLA.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I,
AS A COAUTHOR, I RISE IN SUPPORT
AS WELL. FOURTH STATE IS
PRECIOUS AND IMPORTANT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY. I THINK ALL OF US
WOULD AGREE ACROSS ANY SPECTRUM
THAT THE STATE TODAY, IN OUR
SOCIETY AND OUR COUNTRY AS TO
WHAT QUALIFIES AS QUALITY
JOURNALISM, ANALYSIS AND
INFORMATION GATHERING AND
PRESENTING, HAS FALLEN QUITE FAR
TO NEW LOWS AND HAVING QUALITY,
UNBIASED AND, EQUALITY ANALYSIS
OF INFORMATION THAT CAN HELP
PEOPLE BE INFORMED TO HELP OUR
SOCIETY GROW AND INTERACT AND
PARTICIPATE IN OUR DEMOCRACY, IS
A CRITICAL, CRITICAL THING. FOR
ALL OF THOSE REASONS AND MORE,
WE SHOULD BE SUPPORTING THIS.
AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR NIELLO,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE WITH AN
ALTERNATIVE VIEWPOINT. I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THE
PRINCIPLE OF WHAT MY FRIEND AND
I DO MEAN MY FRIEND FROM CONTRA
COSTA HAS AS WELL AS THOSE
OTHERS THAT HAVE EXPRESSED THE
SAME THING, AND THAT IS THAT IN
OUR DEMOCRACY, WE DO NEED A
ROBUST PRESS FOR AN INFORMED
PUBLIC TO HOLD US ACCOUNTABLE.
EMPHASIS ON US. AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU, IT GIVES ME GREAT
PAUSE TO ENTERTAIN A PROPOSAL
THAT IS THE US, THE ENTITY THAT
WE EXPRESS EXPECT THIS PRESS TO
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE TO BECOME
DEPENDENT UPON THEIR VERY
EXISTENCE. THERE'S A BIT OF A
DISCONNECT THERE. I WOULD
SUGGEST SO THE NEWS BUSINESS IS
EVOLVING. IT HAS BEEN EVOLVING.
FRANKLY, JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER
INDUSTRY IN THE US AND IN THE
WORLD, THERE'S BEEN A HUGE
DISRUPTION OF ALL INDUSTRIES. A
LOT OF IT DRIVEN BY THE RISE OF
THE INTERNET, A SIGNIFICANT
CONSOLIDATION OF OWNERSHIP. I
SEE IT, I'VE SEEN IT IN THE LAST
DECADE OR TWO IN MY OWN INDUSTRY
. THIS IS NOT UNUSUAL. YES, THE
INTERNET DOES HAVE A LOT TO DO
WITH IT, BUT IT'S A LARGER
CHANGE IN THE BEHAVIOR OF THE
WAY CUSTOMERS, PARTICULARLY NEW
CUSTOMERS, CONSUME THEIR NEWS.
PEOPLE GET THEIR NEWS IN
NONTRADITIONAL WAYS, GO BACK 20
YEARS, AND WE DIDN'T SEE A LOT
OF THE OFFERINGS WE DO NOW.
ROBUST OFFERINGS, PODCASTS, MANY
QUALITY PODCASTS, SOME OF THEM
QUESTIONABLE. OF COURSE, BUT
THAT HAPPENS IN ANY MARKETPLACE.
THEY ARE QUITE PREVALENT, AS ARE
HIGHLY HIGH QUALITY ONLINE
NEWSLETTERS. PLUS, THERE'S,
THERE ARE FULL NEWS REPORTING
ONLINE NEWSPAPERS LIKE A NEW
MODEL, CAL MATTERS, WHICH IS
SUPPORTED LARGELY BY INDIVIDUAL
DONATIONS AND GRANTS FROM
FOUNDATIONS. THIS IS A NEW MODEL
. THESE ARE ALL NEW MODELS AND
VERY FEW PEOPLE UNDER THE AGE OF
50, WE'LL CALL THEM YOUNGSTERS.
EVEN PICK UP A PAPER NEWSPAPER.
SO THIS IS AN EVOLUTION OF THE
MARKETPLACE AND ONE OF THE
ISSUES IN THE ANALYZES I'VE READ
IS THAT THERE'S BEEN A HUGE
DEMISE OF LOCAL, MORE
NEIGHBORHOOD NEWSPAPERS. ALSO,
NOW WE HAVE OUR MAJOR NEWSPAPER
HERE IN SACRAMENTO, THE BEE.
WHICH OF WHICH? I'M A LONGTIME
AND CONTINUED SUBSCRIBER AND FOR
YEARS HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD
FRIENDS WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF
THAT NEWSPAPER, BOTH ON THE
JOURNALISM AND THE EDITORIAL
SIDE. BUT WE HAVE A ROBUST
NETWORK OF LOCAL NEWS MEDIA IN
OUR REGIONS. HERE. WE HAVE, A
LADY NAMED THEY'RE TRYING TO
COMPETE WITH ME, A LADY NAMED
CECILY HASTINGS HAS INSIDE
SACRAMENTO, WHICH PUBLISHES
NEWSLETTERS AND LAND PARK, AND,
SEVERAL DIFFERENT INDIVIDUAL
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE AREA. GOLD
COUNTRY MEDIA, WHO'S ACTUALLY
GROWN TO OWN ADDITIONAL
PUBLICATIONS. THE MESSENGER
PUBLISHER GROUP OUT OF RANCHO
CORDOVA, THE SACRAMENTO
OBSERVER, ONE OF THE OWNERS OF
THOSE GROUPS I TALKED TO. AND HE
IS ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION, BOTH, THE BILL
BEFORE US, AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WICKS BILL THAT OUR
JUDICIAL, COMMITTEE DID, RECEIVE
EARLIER THIS WEEK. IT'S ALSO
REALLY IMPORTANT TO REALIZE, TO
UNDERSTAND THAT COINCIDENT WITH
THE EVOLUTION AND THE
CONSOLIDATION GOING ON IN THE
INDUSTRY, THAT OVER HALF OF
DAILY US NEWSPAPERS ARE OWNED BY
HEDGE FUNDS AND INDIVIDUAL
INVESTORS. THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAPPENS WHEN A
INDUSTRY GOES THROUGH A DRASTIC
EVOLUTION, IS INVESTORS COME IN
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE FROM POTENTIAL
PROFIT OPPORTUNITIES, INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. I DON'T SLIGHT
THAT AT ALL. I AM AN UNABASHED
CAPITALIST MYSELF, BUT THEY'RE
NOT BUYING THESE NEWSPAPER
GROUPS FOR THE SAKE OF THE
MISSION OF NEWS REPORTING TO
THEM. IT'S A BUSINESS DEAL ONE
HAS TO QUESTION WITH REGARD TO
THIS BILL AND ASSEMBLYWOMAN
WICKS BILL, WHO ARE WE SAVING?
AND THEN THERE'S LASTLY, THE
ISSUE OF THE OLD UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. THE ASSUMPTION OF
THIS BILL AND MAYBE MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS BILL, IS THAT, THAT THE
PLATFORMS WILL JUST COMPLY AND
NOT CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR. BUT
AS HAS HAPPENED IN EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES, GERMANY, SPAIN,
FRANCE, AUSTRALIA AND MORE
CLOSELY CANADA, THE PLATFORMS DO
CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR TO COMBAT
WHAT THIS BILL AND THE ASSEMBLY
BILL ATTEMPTS TO DO. I WOULD
ADVISE A BIT MORE CONTEMPLATION
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT IT IS WE
INTEND TO PRESERVE AND EXACTLY
HOW TO DO IT, AND VOTE NO ON
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DODD. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
I VOTED FOR THIS IN RIVAS TAX
AND I TALKED TO I SPOKE TO THE
FACT THAT I THOUGHT THIS WAS A
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE, BUT
I'VE GOT SOME OF THE SIMILAR
CONCERNS THAT MY FRIEND FROM
FAIR OAKS HAS, PARTICULARLY ON
THE HEDGE FUNDS. AND SO I, MR.
PRESIDENT, QUESTIONED THE AUTHOR
. SENATORS, WILL YOU TAKE A
QUESTION? YES SO I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT IN THE AMENDMENTS
YOU HAVE, MORE EMPHASIS ON SMALL
MEDIUM. BUT I, I THINK WHERE
YOU'VE GOT SO MUCH MONEY AT
STAKE AND, AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS TRUTH OR RUMOR, BUT THE
LA TIMES, FOR EXAMPLE, SAID THAT
THEY'D PROBABLY, IN ORDER TO
MAKE THIS WORK, WOULD NEED LIKE
80% OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE'RE PUTTING FORWARD. SO I
GUESS WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR, I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ALLOW THE BOTH OF YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS DURING
THE BREAK. BUT WHAT I'D LIKE TO
SEE IS BY THE TIME THIS COMES
BACK TO THE FLOOR, THAT WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF SEE,
YOU KNOW, NOT MAYBE A FIRM
SPENDING, PROGRAM, BUT AT LEAST
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN THOUGHT
OUT AND SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN
THOUGHT OUT PARTICULARLY. SO
WE'RE NOT FUNDING HEDGE FUNDS,
YOU KNOW, YOU KNOW, ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT THAT
HAVE BOUGHT OUT THESE PAPERS. SO
ARE IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN DO? EACH EACH MEDIA OUTLET
HAS THE ABILITY TO CALCULATE HOW
THEY WOULD DO UNDER THE TERMS OF
THIS BILL, AS IT'S PRESENTED
TODAY. SO THAT'S A CALCULATION
THAT THEY CAN MAKE BECAUSE OF
THEIR PROPRIETARY INFORMATION
THEY HAVE OF HOW MANY
JOURNALISTS WOULD FULFILL THEIR
OBLIGATIONS UNDER THE BILL. AND
AND, AND THE REST. SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
ANY OUTLET TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND
WITH THEM IN COOPERATION WITH
THEM. AND THE LAST THING I WOULD
SAY IS THAT, YOU KNOW, IN OUR
HISTORY IN CALIFORNIA, WE'VE HAD
MEDIA OUTLETS THAT HAVE BEEN
THAT WERE PUBLISHERS HAVE BEEN
DISLIKED BECAUSE OF THEIR
ENTERPRISES, THAT THEY MAY BE
INVOLVED IN, WHETHER IT'S THE
RAILROAD OR LAND OWNERSHIP OR
THE REST. AND I WON'T NAME ALL
THE DIFFERENT OWNERS
HISTORICALLY, OF PUBLICATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THEY'VE ALWAYS,
NOT ALWAYS BEEN SO POPULAR.
SOMETIMES THEIR POLITICS. BUT
THIS MEASURE IS WRITTEN IN A
CONTENT NEUTRAL WAY AND IN AN
OWNERSHIP NEUTRAL WAY, NOT TO
PICK WINNERS OR LOSERS. AND
THAT'S THE WAY THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY CRAFTED. THANK YOU. ON
MY OWN TIME, I APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THE SENATOR FROM
ORINDA IS GOING TO CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS. I WOULD
SUGGEST, THOUGH, THAT WE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT BETTER IDEA OF WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND THE MONEY,
WHERE THE GUARDRAILS ARE GOING
TO BE ON CERTAIN SITUATIONS. I
DO APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO TRY TO PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS, BUT IF WE
HAVE A POT OF MONEY THAT,
DOESN'T GO ANYWHERE FAR ENOUGH,
WE'VE GOT TO REALLY ASSESS WHAT
THE VALUE OF THIS IS. BUT FOR
TODAY, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS. WE NEED
ALTERNATIVES IN OUR NEWS
INDUSTRY. WE'VE LOST OVER 60% OF
NEWSPAPERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
LEAVING ONE MESSAGE, ONE
NARRATIVE. AND WE ARE SPENT A
LOT OF OUR TIME TALKING ABOUT
NARRATIVES AND HOW NARRATIVES
DRIVE GOVERNANCE, HOW NARRATIVES
DRIVE THE ABILITY FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THEIR OWN DEMOCRACY, THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN NEWSPAPERS
AND INDUSTRY, YOU KNOW, AS A
FORMER JOURNALIST, IT WAS ALWAYS
THE ADVERTISERS WHO DICTATED
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE NEWSPAPER.
AND AS SENATOR, NILO MENTIONED,
BUSINESS, FAR TOO OFTEN MADE THE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE DIRECTION OF
NEWSPAPERS. AND CERTAINLY THE
INDUSTRY HAS EVOLVED. AND NOW
THE INDUSTRY, THAT IS DRIVING
HOW WE GET OUR NEWS, HAS FOUND
THESE WAYS OF GETTING AROUND
INVESTING IN BUILDING AND
SUPPORTING THE FREEDOM OF OUR
PRESS AND THE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION. I THINK THIS BILL
GIVES MORE TOOLS TO DEAL WITH
THE MODERN DAY ADVERTISERS AND
INDUSTRIES THAT DICTATE WHETHER
WE HAVE ACCESS TO FREE PRESS AND
ALTERNATIVES. THIS BILL,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS BILL,
THESE ARE EFFORTS TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AND I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK,
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE THE
ALTERNATIVES ALSO MUST INCLUDE
BUILDING A REPRESENTATIVE
WORKFORCE WITHIN THE NEWSPAPER
INDUSTRY, WHICH THIS BILL ALSO
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT, ENSURING
THAT THOSE WHO LOOK LIKE
CALIFORNIA TELL THE STORY OF
CALIFORNIA IN OUR PRESS. SO
THESE ARE WIN WIN OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS IS ABOUT MODERNIZING THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE PRESS
AND INDUSTRY AND ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIANS COME OUT ON TOP
WITH A PRESS THAT GIVES
ALTERNATIVES OF VOICE, IDEAS,
AND THE POWER TO DRIVE OUR
DEMOCRACY. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER
. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL, I PARTICULARLY LIKE
THE FEATURES IN THE BILL THAT
WOULD ENSURE THAT ANY
JOURNALISTIC OUTLET THAT IS
FUNDED WITH THIS FUNDS HAS
ACTUAL JOURNALISTS, REPORTERS
WORKING. AND I RAISE THAT
BECAUSE, AS I THINK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA POINTED OUT,
I THINK YOU DID POINT OUT THAT,
YOU KNOW, LA TIMES DESCRIBED
THAT THEY MIGHT NEED ALL THE
FUNDS TO DO WHATEVER THEY HAD IN
MIND, WHICH I'M LESS CONCERNED
ABOUT. THOSE THOSE JOURNALISTIC
OUTLETS THAT ARE ALREADY HAVE,
SAY, HEDGE FUND OWNERS. AND I'M
THINKING ABOUT OUR DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY PAPERS AND OUR ETHNIC
PRESS, AND THAT WE DO NOT WANT
TO BE IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
ONLY NEWS WE READ WAS PRODUCED
BY I. WE WANT JOURNALISTS AND
REPORTERS PRODUCING SOME OF THIS
MATERIAL AND INFORMATION. SO I
THINK THAT THIS WOULD HELP US. I
THINK IT'S A GOOD COMPLEMENT TO
OUR ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUE'S BILL,
AND I ASK FOR ENCOURAGED AND I
VOTE THANK YOU. SENATOR LAIRD.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, I WAS
LISTENING CLOSELY TO THE DEBATE
AND THERE WAS A CONCERN RAISED
ABOUT HOW JOURNALISM IS EVOLVING
AND DOES THIS BILL, IN FACT,
KEEP UP WITH THE WAY JOURNALISM
IS EVOLVING AND LET ME GIVE YOU
A VERY PERSONAL CASE STORY,
BECAUSE IF YOU IF YOU LOOK AT MY
HOMETOWN NEWSPAPER, WHICH WAS
OWNED FOR 109 YEARS BY THE
MCPHERSON FAMILY, Ã MCPHERSON
SAT ON THIS FLOOR FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS AS A SENATOR. THEY'VE
REDUCED TO FOUR REPORTERS. THEY
ARE OWNED BY A HEDGE FUND, AND
THEY GO TO PRINT AT 2:00 ON THE
AFTERNOON. THE DAY BEFORE THE
DATE ON THEIR MASTHEAD. BY THE
TIME YOU READ THEIR NEWSPAPER,
THE WHOLE WORLD HAS PASSED. IT
BY. SO THREE YEARS AGO, A
JOURNALIST THAT HAD BEEN WITH
MCCLATCHY NATIONALLY CAME BACK
TO SANTA CRUZ AND DECIDED HE WAS
GOING TO START AN ONLINE
NEWSPAPER. AND LOOK OUT, SANTA
CRUZ IS THREE YEARS OLD. IT HAS
TONS OF SUBSCRIBERS. IT IS THE
GO TO PLACE FOR SO MANY THINGS
NOW. AND IN THE STORMS, WHEN THE
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS RIPPED US A
YEAR AGO JANUARY, ALL TEN
REPORTERS THERE IN REAL TIME
WERE ON THE STORMS WHEN THE
WHARF WENT DOWN IN CAPITOLA,
THEY WERE UP WITH PICTURES IN
THE NEWS. RIGHT AWAY. WHEN THE
LEVEE BROKE IN PAJARO. THEY WERE
THERE. WE HAD IT IN REAL TIME.
EXACTLY WHAT WAS HAPPENING, WHEN
DOWNTOWN SOCAL FLOODED, THEY
WERE THERE. THEY HAD IT THE MUD
IT OUT MOBILE HOME PARKS. WE ALL
WENT THERE. THAT IS WHERE WE GOT
OUR NEWS IN THE MOMENT. AND IT
WAS A WITH A GREAT PRIDE THAT A
COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO I WALKED
OVER TO THE SENATOR WHO'S
AUTHORED THIS BILL AND SAID THEY
JUST ANNOUNCED THE PULITZERS AND
LOOK OUT, SANTA CRUZ WON A
PULITZER. AND SO THIS BILL WOULD
ACTUALLY APPLY TO THEM. THIS
BILL WOULD ACTUALLY GO TO NEWS
SERVICES LIKE THAT. SO WHILE IT
WAS SAID THAT IT'S EVOLVING,
THIS BILL CAPTURES THE EVOLUTION
OF THE NEWS INDUSTRY AND MAKES
SURE THAT THOSE OF US THAT WANT
A SERVICE LIKE THAT, THIS
MORNING, THEY THEY HAD A GREAT
STORY ON A ROAD OUTAGE IN THE
MOUNTAINS. AND EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN A WAY THAT NOBODY
ELSE DOES. AND SO I THINK IT'S
NOT JUST THERE'S THIS VIEW THAT
THIS JUST PROPS UP AN OUTMODED
INDUSTRY. THIS ACTUALLY MOVES
WITH THE INDUSTRY IN A VERY GOOD
WAY AND MAKES SURE THAT THOSE
THAT ARE MINING THIS INFORMATION
AT NO COST, AWAY FROM OTHER
PEOPLE, ARE PART OF THE MIX. SO
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
GIVE THIS AUTHOR A CHANCE TO
WORK WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
AND SEE IF THEY CAN FASHION THE
BEST THING OVER THE BREAK AND
BRING IT BACK TO US, BECAUSE WE
NEED TO ACT. SO I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON SB 1327. THANK YOU,
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES THERE ARE
MANY IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE
CONSIDER. THERE ARE FEW
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WILL HAVE
AN IMPACT BEYOND OUR NEXT
GENERATION. AND THIS IS ONE THE
ISSUE OF WHAT WE DO TO SUPPORT
CREDIBLE JOURNALISM HAS
REVERBERATIONS FOR, WELL, WELL
BEYOND OUR TIME HERE AND BEYOND
OUR GRANDCHILDREN'S TIME HERE.
AND THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT FOLKS
ARE NOT READING NEWSPAPERS LIKE
THEY USED TO, MY GRANDDAUGHTER
SAW ME READING A NEWSPAPER AND
ASKED ME WHAT IT WAS AND WHY I
WAS READING IT, AND WHEN I
EXPLAINED WHAT IT WAS AND WHY I
WAS READING IT, SHE CAME TO
VISIT FROM SAN FRANCISCO, AND
SHE BROUGHT ME AN ENTIRE PILE OF
NEWSPAPERS THAT SHE COLLECTED
FROM DRIVEWAYS BECAUSE SHE
THOUGHT THEY WERE ABANDONED
PROPERTY. THEY WERE ALL A MONTH
OLD, SO NO CONCEPT, NO CONCEPT
OF WHAT A NEWSPAPER IS AND WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT. PEOPLE NOW GET
THEIR NEWS ONLINE. THAT'S A
GIVEN FOR THE MOST PART. WHAT'S
ALSO GIVEN IS THAT WE'RE SEEING
A DRAMATIC DECLINE, CERTAINLY IN
THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES, A
DRAMATIC DECLINE IN COVERAGE. IF
YOU'VE SEEN YOUR NEWSPAPER, IF
YOU ACTUALLY READ THAT PAPER
PRODUCT, THAT I DO, YOU'VE SEEN
IT'S GOTTEN THINNER AND THINNER
AND THINNER, AND THAT LOCAL
COVERAGE IS LOCAL COVERAGE IS
NOW FAIRLY DE MINIMIS, I WAS
TALKING TO GEORGE SKELTON, WHO
TOLD ME AT ONE TIME THERE WERE
17 LA TIMES REPORTERS HERE
COVERING THE CAPITOL. THERE
AREN'T 17 HERE ANYMORE. AND
THAT'S A PROBLEM. THAT'S A
PROBLEM FOR DEMOCRACY. ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE,
THOUGH, IS COMING TO A PLACE
WHERE WE SUPPORT CREDIBLE
JOURNALISM AND WE MAKE SURE THAT
CONTENT IS STILL AVAILABLE
ONLINE. AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
NO MATTER WHAT WE DO HERE, THAT
THE PLATFORMS WILL CONTINUE TO
CARRY CONTENT IF WE OVERREACH,
IF WE TRY TO STRIKE A AN AMOUNT
OR A PLACE THAT'S TOO FAR, WE'LL
SEE THAT THERE'LL BE NO
COVERAGE, THAT CONTENT WON'T BE
CARRIED, THAT THE MARKETPLACE
WILL MAKE THAT DETERMINATION. SO
OUR CHALLENGE, OUR CHALLENGE IS
TO FIND THE SWEET SPOT WHERE WE
SUPPORT CREDIBLE JOURNALISM, BUT
WE BASICALLY DON'T DRIVE IT FROM
THE PLATFORM. AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT. I THINK
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE, IN
COMBINATION WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS, THAT WE PROVIDE VARIOUS
ALTERNATIVES SO THAT WE CAN GET
TO A PLACE SO THAT WE CAN GET TO
A PLACE BY THE END OF AUGUST
WHERE WE'VE ARRIVED, WHERE
CONTENT WILL STILL BE AVAILABLE
ONLINE, AND THAT CREDIBLE
JOURNALISM WILL BE SUPPORTED.
IT'S A PUBLIC GOOD. IT'S
IMPORTANT. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS VITAL
TO DEMOCRACY. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, I DON'T TYPICALLY
SUPPORT TAXES. I DON'T TYPICALLY
SUPPORT THIS SORT OF, LEVERAGE
TOOL. BUT IN THIS CASE, IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL MICROPHONES UP,
SENATOR GLAZER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU, MEMBERS,
FOR THE ROBUST CONVERSATION THIS
MORNING, EVEN WHEN THERE'S SOME
POINTS THAT ARE MADE THAT IN
WHERE WE DISAGREE, I, I WOULD
SAY JUST TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
THIS, THIS MEASURE IS CONTENT
NEUTRAL OWNERSHIP NEUTRAL. IF A
PUBLISHER OF AN OUTLET, IT
DOESN'T WANT TO HAVE THE
CONNECTION WITH THE GOVERNMENT
THROUGH A TAX CREDIT, THEY DON'T
HAVE TO TAKE THE MONEY. ALL
PLATFORMS ARE ELIGIBLE. AS THE
SENATOR FROM SANTA CRUZ
MENTIONED, THE BILL HAS BEEN
WRITTEN IN A WAY THAT IT
SUPPORTS WORKING JOURNALISTS AT
ANY LEVEL, AT ANY PLATFORM, AS
LONG AS THEY'RE WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA FOR CALIFORNIANS, AND
THAT ONE OF THE ELEMENTS OF THE
BILL THAT I DIDN'T MENTION IN MY
OPENING, THAT'S IMPORTANT IS
THAT IT'S WRITTEN TO NOT JUST
TRY TO STABILIZE, BUT IT'S
WRITTEN WITH INCENTIVES TO GROW.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE NEED. WE
NEED THESE NEWSROOMS TO GROW
AGAIN. AND I THINK THAT HAS BEEN
BUILT INTO THE BILL. YOU KNOW,
WORK LIKE THIS DOESN'T COME IN
AN INSTANT. IT TAKES YEARS OF
ENGAGEMENT. AND THIS BILL
CERTAINLY REFLECTS THAT. I WANT
TO I WANT TO CALL OUT OUR PRO
TEM EMERITUS, TONY ATKINS, WHO
WORKED WITH ME ON THIS ISSUE A
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO, TO TRY TO
SEE THE PROBLEM AND DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
PRO TEM MCGUIRE, WHO'S BEEN A
GREAT PARTNER, COAUTHOR OF THE
BILL AND A GREAT PARTNER. AS A
FORMER JOURNALIST HIMSELF, TO
TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO PATHWAYS
TO HELP DO SOMETHING WHERE WE
BOTH SEE SUCH A SERIOUS PROBLEM,
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
COAUTHORS THAT HAVE JOINED.
CERTAINLY. THANK YOU TO THE
SENATORS FROM ENCINITAS, SAN
DIEGO, NAPA, LÀ, BERKELEY, SANTA
CRUZ, AND SANTA ANA WHO SPOKE
TODAY. THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS. IT'S A BIG PROBLEM,
AND IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE A LOT
MORE THINKING TO FIND THE RIGHT
PATHWAY FORWARD. I'D BE GRATEFUL
IF YOU WOULD ALLOW ME THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY. AND I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON SB 1327 MEMBERS.
THIS REQUIRES 27 VOTES.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA
I ASHBY I ATKINS, I BECKER,
BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD CABALLERO
I CORTEZ I DALLY NÓ DODD I RAZO
EGGMAN GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE
NØ HURTADO I JONES. NO. LAIRD I
LIMON I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MIN
NEWMAN. NGUYEN NO NILO. NO
PADILLA I PORTANTINO. ROTH I
RUBIO. SATO NO. SKINNER I SMALL.
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK. SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL I BECKER.
BRADFORD DURAZO I EGGMAN MIN.
NEWMAN OKUBO. NÓ PORTANTINO.
RUBIO WILK I. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
BECKER BRADFORD I EGGMAN. MIN
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO RUBIO. AYES
27. NOES SEVEN. ON THEIR URGENCY
. AYES 27. NOES SEVEN. ON THE
MEASURE. MEASURE PASSES. I'M
SORRY. NO APPLAUSE, PLEASE.
MEMBERS. NOW WE MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING FILE
ITEM 205 AB 2288. SENATOR
UMBERG, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2288 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR UMBERG, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES. IN
2004, THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
PASSED THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ACT TO BOLSTER THE
STATE'S LABOR ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITIES. AND THIS HAS BEEN
AN ITEM OF CONTROVERSY FOR AT
LEAST THE LAST DECADE, IF NOT
MORE, THE ORIGINAL PURPOSE OF
THE PAGA LAW WAS TO BASICALLY
CREATE AN ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
FOR LABOR VIOLATIONS, SINCE THAT
TIME, THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
ABUSES, AND THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF ACTIONS THAT ACTUALLY
HAVE PROVIDED THAT REQUISITE
LEVEL OF ENFORCEMENT FOR LABOR
VIOLATIONS. AS A TRIBUTE TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS, THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS, THE LABOR, LABOR, FED
, THEY HAVE ALL COME TOGETHER
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS AND
HAMMERED OUT A COMPROMISE, WHICH
IS A HUGE, HUGE TRIBUTE TO THEIR
PASSION AND PRAGMATISM AND THEIR
DEDICATION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO THE RIGHT THING FOR
CALIFORNIA. WHAT THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY DOES IS ENCOURAGES
EMPLOYERS COMPLIANCE BY REDUCING
PENALTIES FOR EMPLOYERS WHO TAKE
REASONABLE STEPS TO QUICKLY FIX
UNLAWFUL POLICIES AND PRACTICES,
WHILE CREATING HIGHER PENALTIES
FOR BAD ACTORS WHO ACT WITH
MALICE. AB 2288 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA IMPROVES OVERALL
OUTCOMES BY ADDING INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF AS A REMEDY, UPDATING THE
SPLIT OF PAGA PENALTIES,
INCREASING WORKERS ABILITY TO
GET BACK WAGES WITH INTEREST,
AND ALLOWING JUDICIAL DISCRETION
TO INCREASE PENALTIES WHERE THE
OUTCOME WOULD OTHERWISE BE
UNJUST. UNJUST. THIS BILL WILL
PROTECT WORKERS AND PROMOTE
EARLY RESOLUTION OF VIOLATIONS,
THERE'S A COMPANION BILL BY
SENATOR UMBERG THAT IS THE OTHER
COMPONENT OF THAT COMPROMISE
THAT WE'LL HEAR, I THINK, LATER
ON TODAY, WITH THAT, I URGE AND
I VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION,
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, HEARING AND
SEEING? NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON. FINAL ITEM
205. ALLEN, I RODA-GIL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY DODD
I RAZO I EGGMAN I GLASER
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA I PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK I SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BECKER I
DALY. GLASER I. I 39 NOES ZERO
ON THE URGENCY. AYES 39 NOES
ZERO ON THE MEASURE. MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 208.
SENATOR GLAZIER, ARE YOU
PREPARED? FILE ITEM 208. ACA
TI¾N SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FINANCE.
SENATOR GLAZIER THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER
AGUIAR-CURRY, I'M PRESENTING ACA
TEN TO REMOVE THE SPECIAL TAX
PROVISION CURRENTLY IN ACA ONE,
WHICH THIS BODY PASSED LAST
YEAR. ACA ONE, WHICH WILL APPEAR
ON THE NOVEMBER BALLOT, HELPS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FUND CRITICAL
HOUSING AND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS BY
REDUCING THE VOTE THRESHOLD FROM
TWO THIRDS TO 55% FOR BOTH
SPECIAL TAXES AND BONDS. THIS
MEASURE REMOVES THE SPECIAL
TAXES. WITH THIS CHANGE, ACA ONE
CONTINUES TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OBTAIN FUNDS BY
REDUCING THE VOTE THRESHOLD FOR
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS. I
SUPPORTED ACA ONE LAST YEAR. I
SUPPORT ACA TEN. THAT TAKES A
MODEST YET IMPACTFUL APPROACH TO
BUILD OUR SORELY NEEDED HOUSING
AND INFRASTRUCTURE, AND TO
REMIND MEMBERS THIS IS ALL
DETERMINED UPON A LOCAL VOTE OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WANT TO
ADVANCE THIS WORK. I COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR HER WORK ON THESE
MEASURES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 208. ALLEN I
ALVARADO. GILL ARCHULETA I ASHBY
I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE SPEER
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CORTEZ
DALLEY NÓ DODD I RAZO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE NØ.
HURTADO I JONES. NO LAIRD I
LIMÓN I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN
I NEWMAN I NGUYEN. NO NILO NO
OKOBO NO. PADILLA I PORTANTINO I
ROTH I RUBIO. SATO NO. SKINNER I
SMILED. CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG
, I WAHAB, I WIENER I WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO, GILL. CORTEZ I RUBIO I
. ISE 31 NOES EIGHT. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE MOVE IN
TO FILE ITEM 207.
SENATORS, NEXT. TWO FILE ITEMS
ARE ON DECK OR FILE ITEM 207 AND
FILE ITEM 202. SENATOR BRADFORD
IS READY FOR FIREARM 207.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY. CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON. AN ACT RELATING
TO SLAVERY. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE TODAY AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF ACA EIGHT, A
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS PRIORITY THAT WOULD ALLOW
VOTERS TO, ONCE AND FOR ALL,
BANNED SLAVERY AND INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE WITHOUT EXCEPTION, IN
OUR STATE. THIS MEASURE WOULD,
IF PASSED AND APPROVED BY
VOTERS, AMEND ARTICLE ONE,
SECTION SIX OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION TO REMOVE THE
EXISTING EXCEPTIONS TO BAN ON
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE AS
PUNISHMENT FOR A CRIME, AND
WOULD ENSURE THAT PRISONS CANNOT
PUNISH INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
FOR PRIORITIZING REHABILITATION
OVER ASSIGNMENTS. TODAY, SLAVERY
TAKES ON MODERN FORM OF
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE, INCLUDING
FORCED LABOR IN PRISONS. SLAVERY
IS WRONG IN ALL FORMS AND
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE CLEAR IN
DENOUNCING THAT IN OUR
CONSTITUTION, THIS SHOULD NOT BE
A CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE. IT IS
OFTEN ASSUMED THAT SLAVERY AND
FORCED LABOR ARE THINGS OF THE
PAST. BUT TO OUR DETRIMENT. WE
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE TODAY THAT
HAVE THEIR ROOTS IN AND CARCERAL
SYSTEM THAT MAINTAINS VESTIGES
OF SLAVERY. AFTER THE
EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION AND
THE PASSAGE OF THE 13TH
AMENDMENT, THE FORMER SLAVE
STATES, EVEN FREE STATES, WOULD
TARGET BLACK AMERICANS FOR
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION AND USE
THAT EXCEPTION OF INVOLUNTARY
SERVITUDE TO EXPLOIT FORMER
SLAVES AND THEIR DESCENDANTS
THROUGH FORCED PRISON LABOR.
CALIFORNIA IS AMONG ONLY 16
STATES WITH AN EXCEPTION CLAUSE
FOR INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE IN THE
STATE'S CONSTITUTION. MOST
RECENTLY, VOTERS IN ALABAMA,
OREGON, TENNESSEE, AND VERMONT
REMOVED INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
LANGUAGE FROM THEIR STATE'S
CONSTITUTION. INCARCERATED
PEOPLE HAVE LONG FACED CRUEL
TREATMENT FOR ANY WORK ABSENCE.
THIS INCLUDES PHYSICAL VIOLENCE,
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT, DENIAL OF
PHONE CALLS AND FAMILY VISITS,
LIMITING PARTICIPATION IN
SELF-HELP GROUPS, AND
DISCIPLINARY WRITE UPS THAT
RESULT IN LONGER PRISON TERMS.
SUCH PUNISHMENTS, OR THREATS OF
SUCH PUNISHMENTS ARE OFTEN
ISSUED EVEN WHEN ABSENCES ARE
DUE TO ILLNESS OR INJURIES
SUSTAINED THROUGH WORK. THE
CURRENT PRACTICE OF FORCED LABOR
DOES NOT PREPARE INCARCERATED
PEOPLE FOR SUCCESS UPON REENTRY,
AND OFTEN PREVENTS PARTICIPATION
IN REHABILITATIVE SERVICES.
INCARCERATED PEOPLE, PEOPLE'S
RELATIONSHIP TO WORK SHOULD NOT
BE ONE OF EXPLOITATION AND
LITTLE TO DO WITH AGENCY. LET US
TAKE THIS STEP TO RESTORE SOME
DIGNITY AND HUMANITY AND
PRIORITIZE REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES FOR THE OFTEN FORGOTTEN
INDIVIDUALS BEHIND BARS. THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THIS ASSEMBLY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR BRADFORD.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND I WANT TO THANK
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA
FOR HIS WORDS IN TERMS OF THE
HISTORY AND THE ROOTS OF
INDENTURED SERVITUDE AND WHY WE
MUST STAND IN SUPPORT. ACA
EIGHT, WHICH IS OUR PRIORITY.
BILL OF THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS REPARATIONS PACKAGE. AC
EIGHT IS LONG OVERDUE IN
PREVENTING INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE
, WHICH UNDERMINES ALL WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN YOU HAVE FOLKS
IN A PRISON WHO ARE MAKING TWO
AND FIVE AND $0.08 AN HOUR, IT
UNDERMINES EVERYONE'S ABILITY TO
EARN A LIVING WAGE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IT ALSO
NORMALIZES EXPLOITATION. IT
NORMALIZES INDIGNITY AND
INHUMANITY. IT NORMALIZES THE
VERY THINGS THAT WE WORK FOR IN
OUR LEGISLATURE IN TERMS OF WHAT
IS A WAGE STANDARD, AND THAT ALL
WORK HAS DIGNITY AS WE DO THE
WORK OF REPARATIONS, WE REFER TO
SLAVERY AS A RELIC OF THE PAST.
BUT AS I STAND HERE TODAY, WE
HAVE THOUSANDS OF INDENTURED
SERVANTS IN OUR PENAL SYSTEM
WHO, WHEN ASKED ABOUT THEIR
WORK, I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY SPEAK TO SOME FOLKS
DOWN IN LANCASTER WHO WHO WERE
HOUSED IN RESIDENTS OF THE
PRISON THERE, AND THEY WERE
TELLING ME ABOUT THE WORK THEY
WERE DOING AS PLUMBERS IN THAT
PRISON AND THAT THEY WERE MAKING
WHAT THIS WAS THE MOST POPULAR
JOB, A LOT OF COMPETITION FOR
THIS JOB, BECAUSE IT PAID $0.08
AN HOUR. AND WHEN I ASKED THIS
INDIVIDUAL, WELL, HAVE YOU EVER
HEARD OF THE PLUMBERS UNION? DID
YOU KNOW THAT THERE IS ACTUALLY
A CERTIFICATION AND
APPRENTICESHIP TO BECOME A
PLUMBER? THEY DID NOT. SO WHEN
WE SAY INDENTURED SERVITUDE, WE
ARE CREATING NOT JUST THAT
REALITY FOR FOLKS IN OUR PRISONS
, BUT A MINDSET FOR WHEN THEY
COME OUT OF PRISON. AND SO IT'S
UPON US TO TAKE UP THIS ISSUE,
THAT FREE LABOR OF BLACK PEOPLE
THAT BUILT THIS NATION, THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO REPAIR SO MANY OF
THE HARMS OF THAT WE TAKE THE
STEP TO ERADICATE AND REMOVE
THIS LANGUAGE FROM OUR
CONSTITUTION IN A TIME WHERE WE
ARE ENFORCING MORE LAWS TO PUSH
MORE PEOPLE INTO OUR PRISONS IN
THIS VERY MOMENT, WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THESE INSTITUTIONS
REALLY ARE ABOUT REHABILITATION,
NORMALIZING WORK, NORMALIZING
THE IDEA THAT THEY FOLKS CAN
HAVE AND REACH A QUALITY JOB,
AND ENSURING THAT WE RESTORE THE
VALUES THAT WE STAND ON OUTSIDE
OF OUR PRISONS, THAT WE BUILD
OUR VALUES INSIDE OF OUR PRISON
BY REMOVING INDENTURED SERVITUDE
FROM THE LANGUAGE OF THIS GREAT
STATE. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SENATOR DODD, DO YOU
RECOGNIZED? YES, MADAM
PRESIDENT, I'LL BE. I'LL BE
BRIEF. I APPRECIATE THIS
RESOLUTION OR THIS, AC EIGHT IN
SUPPORTING IT TODAY, BUT I THIS
IS KIND OF NOT CUSTOMARY. THIS
CAME UP BEFORE, IN OUR HOUSE,
AND IT DID NOT PASS. AND I JUST
THINK THE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM,
SASSOON, CALIFORNIA, DID A
WONDERFUL JOB NEGOTIATING WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND THE
LEADERSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
HOUSES. THIS WAS A GREAT WORK ON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON'S BEHALF.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR. AYE. VOTE.
SEE NO FURTHER MICS GOING UP.
SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AND
I'M GOING TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
WHO LET THEIR VOICES ON THIS
ISSUE, AGAIN, WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THAT MASS
INCARCERATION WAS A DIRECT
RESULT AFTER THE ENDING OF
SLAVERY. AFTER THE SIGNING OF
THE EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION IN
1863 AND, AMENDMENT AMENDING
PROPOSITION, I MEAN, THE 13TH
AMENDMENT ON OUR CONSTITUTION.
PRIOR TO THAT, WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE TYPE OF, INCARCERATION THAT
WE HAD. AND THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
THAT WAS JUST TO FORCE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE JUST
RECENTLY FREED TO GO BACK AND
WORK ON THOSE SAME PLANTATIONS
THAT THEY WERE LIBERATED FROM
THE LEGACY OF SLAVERY AND FORCED
LABOR RUNS DEEP IN CALIFORNIA,
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY, FROM THE
EXPLOITATION OF OUR INDIGENOUS
BROTHERS AND SISTERS TO THE
EXPLOITATION OF OUR CHINESE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO WERE
FORCED TO WORK ON THE RAILROADS,
OUR LATINO BROTHERS AND SISTERS
AND FILIPINO BROTHERS AND
SISTERS WHO WERE FORCED TO WORK
ON FARMLANDS AND TO BLACK SLAVES
FORCED TO MINE FOR GOLD HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TODAY,
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TOWARDS ENDING THAT LEGACY.
MEMBERS, I STRONGLY ASK FOR OUR
AYE VOTE ON ACA THREE EIGHT.
REMINDING OUR GUESTS, FOR NO
CLAPPING AT THE END OF THE VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS, I
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY DODD. AYE.
TERRAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE
. HURTADO AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NEELO. OKOBO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DAWLEY.
NO GROVE. JONES LIMÓN. AYE.
NGUYEN NEELO. NO. WATROBA SATO.
NO ISE 33 NOES. THREE. THE
MEASURE PASSES. I'M GOING TO ASK
OUR GUESTS TO PLEASE STAY QUIET.
OUR GUESTS RESPECTFULLY ASKING
IF WE CAN PLEASE STAY QUIET. WE
HAVE FURTHER BUSINESS TO
CONTINUE. WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FREEDOM 202. SENATOR BRADFORD IS
ONCE AGAIN READY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. AS OUR GUEST. IF WE
COULD PLEASE REMAIN QUIET. WE
HAVE MORE BUSINESS TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH. ASSEMBLY BILL 628
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON. AN
ACT RELATING TO PRISONS. SENATOR
BRADFORD, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AB 628 IS THE
COMPANION BILL OF AK AK EIGHT
THAT WE JUST PASSED. CONTINUING
UPON THE PASSAGE. BRADFORD.
SENATOR BRADFORD, WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A QUICK OH I'M SORRY. YEAH.
ONE MOMENT. SENATOR BRADFORD.
YOU MAY PROCEED. SENATOR
CONTINUED ON THE PASSAGE AND
APPROVAL OF AK EIGHT BY THE
VOTERS, AB 628 WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION,
BETTER KNOWN AS CDCR, TO CREATE
A VOLUNTARY WORK PROGRAM,
FURTHERMORE CLARIFIES THAT CDCR
AND THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SETTING
COMPENSATION FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS BY REMOVING THE LONG
STANDING EXCEPTION TO
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE FOR
PUNISHMENT OF A CRIME. WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESTORE SOME
HUMANITY TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO
DEHUMANIZING PRACTICES. WE KNOW
THAT OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IMPACTS BLACK, BROWN, AND
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES AT A
LEVEL DISPROPORTIONATE WITH THE
CRIMES COMMITTED. BLACK
AMERICANS ARE INCARCERATED AT IN
THIS STATE PRISONS AT NEARLY
FIVE TIMES THE RATE OF OUR WHITE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. ONCE
ARRESTED, BLACK AMERICANS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO REMAIN IN PRISON
LONGER AND AWAIT TRIAL FOR MINOR
OFFENSES AT A HIGHER RATE THAN
OUR WHITE COUNTERPARTS. IF WE
CANNOT RECOGNIZE THESE FACTS,
THEN WE'LL WE'RE BLIND. THEN WE
BLIND OURSELVES TO THE CONTINUED
DEHUMANIZATION OF BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES THROUGH THE
USE OF FORCED LABOR THAT IS TIED
TO OUR RACIST HISTORY OF SLAVERY
AND INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE. THERE
IS MUCH WORK TO BE DONE TO RIGHT
THESE PRESENT AND HISTORICAL
WRONGS, WHICH CANNOT BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH THESE MEASURES
ALONE. BUT THIS BILL IS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP TOWARD
RESTORING THE HUMANITY AND
DIGNITY OF ALL HUMANS, EVEN
THOSE GUILTY OF CRIMES. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE WORK
ASSIGNMENTS FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE VOLUNTARY, AND
THEY WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO
DISCIPLINE FOR REFUSING A WORK
ASSIGNMENT, ALLOWING FOR GREATER
PARTICIPATION IN REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS, AND
HELPING RESTORE DIGNITY AND
BODILY AUTONOMY AND INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS. THE CURRENT
PRACTICE OF FORCED LABOR DOES
NOT PREPARE INCARCERATED PEOPLE
FOR SUCCESS UPON REENTRY, AND
ALSO PREVENTS PARTICIPATION IN
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS. THIS
BILL CLARIFIES THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ACR EIGHT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR, I'M SEEING
NO MIKES GOING UP. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ALVARADO GILL I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I TALLEY DODD I TORAZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE HURTADO I JONES LAIRD I
LIMÓN I MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR I MIN
I NEWMAN. I NGUYEN NILO NØ OKOBO
. PODIUM I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. SKINNER I. SATO.
NO. SKINNER I SMALL. CUEVAS I
STERN I UMBERG, I WAHAB I WIENER
. I WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DOLLY GROVE JONES
MCGUIRE I NGUYEN OKUBO WILK I
AYES 33 NOES TO THE MEASURE
PASSES. COMING UP. COLLEAGUES,
WE HAVE FILE ITEM 206 AB 2927.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 2927 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. AN ACT RELATING TO
PUPIL INSTRUCTION, MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION, THEREFORE, AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
LIMÓN, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES, TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 2927 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY, A BIPARTISAN
BILL WITH NO VOTES IN OPPOSITION
. AB 2927 INTRODUCES YOUNG
CALIFORNIANS TO FINANCIAL
LITERACY BY REQUIRING A SEMESTER
OF PERSONAL FINANCE TO GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL, STARTING WITH
THE 2031 CLASS. CALIFORNIA HAS
FALLEN BEHIND AS 17 OTHER STATES
IN THE U.S. ALREADY REQUIRE A
COURSE. ONLY 1% OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE GUARANTEED A
PERSONAL FINANCE COURSE,
COMPARED TO 53% OF STUDENTS
NATIONWIDE. OVER 75% OF STUDENTS
SURVEYED ANSWERED THAT THEY
GAINED THEIR FINANCIAL
UNDERSTANDING FROM UNCHECKED
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS. A
MAJORITY OF OUR STUDENTS ENTER
HIGHER EDUCATION AND THE
WORKFORCE WITHOUT BASIC
FINANCIAL LITERACY, AND DON'T
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THINGS LIKE A DEBIT CARD AND A
CREDIT CARD. THOSE WITH HIGHER
FINANCIAL LITERACY ARE MORE
LIKELY TO INVEST IN SAVINGS,
PREPARE FOR RETIREMENT, AND
MANAGE THEIR DEBT. THE TITAN
PARTNERS REPORTED THAT THE
LIFETIME BENEFIT OF TAKING THIS
COURSE FOR EACH CALIFORNIA
STUDENT IS $127,000. SCHOOLS
WITH PREDOMINANTLY HIGHER INCOME
ARE THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
OFFER FINANCE COURSES COMPARED
TO LOWER INCOME SCHOOLS, WHERE
THERE ARE MANY STUDENTS OF
COLOR. EARLY POLLING SHOWS THAT
85% OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PERSONAL
FINANCE COURSE IN HIGH SCHOOLS.
AB 2927 IS OVERDUE INVESTMENT,
AND AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE, I
ASK THAT WE INVEST IN FUTURE
GENERATIONS WITH THIS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
DEBATE OR CONVERSATION ON THIS
ITEM? SENATOR DALLA? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT. I THINK THIS IS VERY
CRITICAL TO TEACH OUR YOUNGER
GENERATION THE ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND, EVEN INTEREST HOW IT
COMPOUNDS AGAINST YOU AND HOW IT
CAN COMPOUND FOR YOU. SO FOR
MANY OTHER REASONS, I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. I THINK WE
NEED TO BE DOING THIS, JUST THE
ABILITY TO EVEN BALANCE A
CHECKBOOK. MY OWN CHILDREN,
STARTED OUT YOUNG LEARNING THOSE
THOSE LIFE SKILLS THAT THEY
NEED, IF THEY DON'T GO FURTHER
THAN HIGH SCHOOL, THEY
DEFINITELY NEED THOSE. SO STAND
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS? DISCUSSION
BY AUTHORS. SENATOR SATO, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. I
TOO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL, IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO SOME
BILLS WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST
THAT HAVE SOMEHOW FAILED, OUT OF
COMMITTEE, AND, YOU KNOW, THE
LONGER WE WAIT, THE LESS
LITERATE OUR KIDS BECOME IN, IN
FINANCIAL LITERACY, WHEN YOU
TALK TO YOUNG PEOPLE, I'VE
TALKED TO SOME PEOPLE THAT ARE
THERE, ATHLETES THAT ARE
SUDDENLY MAKING A LOT OF MONEY
AND ONE OF THEIR SHORTCOMINGS
THAT THEY SAY SOMEBODY THEY WISH
SOMEBODY HAD TAUGHT THEM
SOMETHING ABOUT FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT AND LITERACY. AND
THAT'S WHY THIS HAS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
ATTEMPTED, I'M FINALLY I'M GLAD
THAT WE HAVE FINALLY DECIDED
THAT IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD PUT INTO OUR CURRICULUM,
AND I, I'M AFRAID, YOU KNOW, IF
IT'S JUST IN LIEU OF SOMETHING
ELSE THAT WE'RE MISSING
SOMETHING ELSE. THIS SHOULD BE
INTRODUCED INTO THE CURRICULUM
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE, AND NOT
BE A REQUIREMENT, BUT IT SHOULD
BE IN WHAT WE ALREADY REQUIRE,
BECAUSE THEN WE'RE EXTENDING
PEOPLE'S THE DIFFICULTY IN SOME
OF OUR KIDS EVEN TRYING TO, TO
GRADUATE AS THEY, THEY
ACCUMULATE ALL THESE DIFFERENT,
REQUIRED COURSES BEFORE THEY
GRADUATE. SO, VERY HAPPY TO SEE
THIS MOVE FORWARD, I HOPE THE
GOVERNOR SIGNS IT. AND I APPLAUD
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO FINALLY LET
THIS THROUGH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR CHROBOG. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. SO THIS IS GOING
TO COME TO AN IRONY BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN AN ADVOCATE FOR FINANCIAL
LITERACY, AT EVERY COURSE, EVERY
SINGLE YEAR THAT I'VE BEEN HERE
IN EDUCATION, SUPPORTED EVERY
SINGLE BILL WITH REGARDS TO
FINANCIAL LITERACY AS BEING
SOMETHING THAT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT, FOR EVERY, SENIOR OR
EVERY HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATE TO,
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH, ESPECIALLY
IN REAL ESTATE. I REMEMBER WHEN
I FIRST STARTED WORKING IN REAL
ESTATE, OVER 20 YEARS AGO, I
REMEMBER THINKING, HOW ARE THESE
PEOPLE AFFORD ARE THESE
BEAUTIFUL HOMES AND CARS AND SO
FORTH. AND WHEN THE RECESSION
CAME IN 0708, I THINK IT WAS
ZERO EIGHT, I REMEMBER THE DEBT
THAT PEOPLE WENT INTO AND THE
DEFAULT AND HOW PEOPLE LOST
THEIR HOMES AND HAD TO SELL
THEIR CARS AND HAD TO MOVE OUT
OF STATE, SO FINANCIAL LITERACY
HAS ALWAYS BEEN AT THE BEDROCK
OF IMPORTANCE FOR ME PERSONALLY
TO ENSURE THAT EVERYONE,
INCLUDING MY CLIENTS, INCLUDING
MY CHILDREN, UNDERSTOOD A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT FINANCIAL LITERACY.
HOWEVER, WITH THIS PARTICULAR
BILL AND I HAVE IN, IN, IN
COMMITTEE HAVE SUPPORTED EVERY
FINANCIAL LITERACY. HOWEVER, THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL AND IT JUST
ABSOLUTELY DISAPPOINTED ME WAS
THE FACT THAT IT WAS IN LIEU OF
TAKING ECONOMICS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND SO WITH THAT, I WAS SO
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT,
BECAUSE IF WE HAVE OUR SENIORS,
OUR HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES
FINISHING HIGH SCHOOL AND THEY
DON'T PURSUE ANY OTHER ACADEMIC
ENDEAVOR, THE, THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO TAKE ECONOMICS AND UNDERSTAND
ECONOMY, IN HOW IT WORKS IN OUR
STATE, IN OUR NATION AND SO
FORTH, ACTUALLY GOES BY THE
WAYSIDE. SO THE ONLY IN THE, THE
ONE AND ONLY OPPORTUNITY THAT
THEY HAVE TO TAKE ECONOMICS
WOULD BE IN HIGH SCHOOL. SO THIS
WOULD BE IN LIEU OF TAKING
ECONOMICS, WHICH I THINK IS ALSO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND, OUR ECONOMY IN OUR
STATE. SO WITH THAT, I WILL BE
ABSTAINING FROM THIS BILL, SO,
SO, DISHEARTENING BECAUSE I
TRULY, TRULY, IN ALL MY HEART
BELIEVE THAT FINANCIAL LITERACY
IS IMPORTANT, BUT NOT IN LIEU OF
UNDERSTANDING ECONOMICS, AND HOW
THAT ACTUALLY IMPACTS OUR DAILY
LIVES IN OUR STATE AND IN OUR
COUNTRY AND IN THE WORLD. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU.
I DO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. I DO HEAR MY COLLEAGUE
JUST SAID ABOUT ECONOMICS, WHICH
I DO BELIEVE IS IMPORTANT AS
WELL, BUT I DO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE. I WANTED TO
NOTE, BECAUSE IT WAS REALLY AN
ADVOCATE, TIM RANZETTA FROM MY
DISTRICT, WHO STARTED A NEXT GEN
PERSONAL FINANCE AND REALLY HAS
LED THIS MOVEMENT. THERE'S NOW
25 STATES THAT REQUIRE THIS
QUITE REMARKABLE 25 STATES.
WE'LL BE JOINING THESE 25 OTHER
STATES IN TAKING THIS STEP. I DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. AND I URGE
AND I VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU. MEMBERS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON. FINAL
ITEM 206 ELLEN I. ALVARADO GILL
I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I TERRAZZO I EGGMAN I
GLASER I GONZALEZ I GROVE I
HURTADO I JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN
I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I SMILED
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBER OKUBO. AYES
39. NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY. AYES
39. NO. ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
MEASURE. PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 204. OKAY
SENATOR BECKER, HE WILL BE
HANDLING THIS ISSUE. SECRETARY,
YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY BILL 2113
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. AN
ACT RELATING TO PESTICIDES AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
BECKER, THANK YOU, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE. I RISE
TO PRESENT AB 2113 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA, WHICH MAKES
POLICY AND MILL ASSESSMENT
CHANGES UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION TO ENSURE
THAT IT CAN ADEQUATELY SUPPORT
ITS STATUTORY AND PROGRAMMATIC
RESPONSIBILITIES. THIS MEASURE
WAS INTRODUCED TO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE AN OPPORTUNITY,
THROUGH THE POLICY COMMITTEE
PROCESS, TO HEAR FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND FURTHER REFINE
BUDGET, IMPLEMENTING LANGUAGE
INCLUDED IN A TRAILER BILL
PROPOSAL. THIS BILL REPRESENTS
AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ASSEMBLY, SENATE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. RECENT
AMENDMENTS STRIKE A COMPROMISE
THAT HAS RESOLVED OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. AMENDMENTS INCLUDE
REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT TO
COMPLETE THE REGISTRATION OF
PESTICIDES BY WITHIN A SPECIFIED
TIME FRAME BEGINNING IN 2027.
SECOND, REMOVING THE AUTHORITY
OF THE DEPARTMENT TO RAISE THE
MILL ASSESSMENT IN THE FUTURE.
THIRD, REQUIRING THE DEPARTMENT
TO INITIATE AN ADDITIONAL
REEVALUATION OF A PESTICIDE A
YEAR UNTIL 2029 AND THEN
INITIATE AN ADDITIONAL TWO
REEVALUATIONS OF A PESTICIDE PER
YEAR, AND FINALLY RAISING THE
MILL ASSESSMENT INCREMENTALLY
OVER FOUR YEARS TO A MAXIMUM OF
30 MILLS. THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES. IT REQUIRES DPR TO
POST-REGISTRATION PESTICIDE
REGISTRATION TIMELINE AND
ESTIMATED TIMELINES FOR
COMPLETION OF REEVALUATION.
REEVALUATION INFORMATION ON THE
WEBSITE, THE MEASURE IS CRITICAL
TO ADDRESSING DPR FUNDING
SHORTFALL SO THAT IT DOES HAVE
THE PROPER RESOURCES TO CARRY
OUT ITS MISSION, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM. OH,
I'M SORRY, I'M SORRY, SENATOR
NILO. SORRY. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO SUGGEST
THAT WE ARE PREMATURE ON THIS, I
HAD REQUESTED AN AUDIT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION AND THE PROCESS
BEHIND THIS PARTICULAR MEASURE.
AND THAT AUDIT HAS BEEN
COMPLETED, AND THE RESULTS ARE
GOING TO BE PUBLISHED NEXT WEEK.
TUESDAY MORNING, 930, I BELIEVE.
SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WE TABLE
THIS MEASURE UNTIL WE FIND OUT
WHAT THE AUDIT SAYS, SO THAT WE
CAN BETTER ASSESS THE EFFICACY
OF THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL. I
SUGGEST THAT YOU EITHER ABSTAIN
OR VOTE NO. SENATOR NILO, IS
THAT A MOTION, SENATOR NILO, WAS
THAT A MOTION, I AM SPEAKING TO
THE MOTION ON THE ON THE FLOOR.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. FINE. GREAT ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING. SEEING?
NONE. SENATOR BECKER, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YEAH, I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERN. I WILL
SAY THE BILL DOES REQUIRE THE
AGREEMENT, WHICH WAS AFTER MUCH
NOTICE, CAME THROUGH MY
SUBCOMMITTEE AND A LOT OF DEBATE
AND DISCUSSION. AND I APPRECIATE
THE CONCERNS. THIS DOES ALSO,
I'LL NOTE, IN ADDITION TO THE
OTHER THINGS I MENTIONED,
REQUIRE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT TO APPEAR BEFORE THE
RESPECTIVE LEGISLATIVE POLICY
COMMITTEES OF THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE, NO LESS THAN AT LEAST
ONCE EVERY TWO YEARS, AGAIN,
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
PROVISIONS THAT WERE PUT INTO
THIS. I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS,
BUT I DO THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO ADDRESS THE FUNDING
SHORTFALL. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 204 ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARO Tê GILL ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALI.
DODD. AYE. DALI NO. BARRASSO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO. HURTADO.
AYE JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN.
AYE. MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MIN. AYE. NEWMAN NEWMAN. AYE.
MIN. NO. WIN NO. NILO. NO. OKOBO
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO
SKINNER I SMILED. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. AYE. WILK. NO SENATOR
BECKER MOVES A CALL NOW.
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 203. SENATOR DODD, ARE YOU
PREPARED FOLLOWING 203? HE IS
SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ ASSEMBLY
BILL 1935 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLANCO RUBIO, AN ACT RELATING TO
TRIBAL GAMING AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY, SENATOR DODD. MR.
PRESIDENT, MEMBERS AB 1935 WOULD
CODIFY A RECENT AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
CALIFORNIA'S FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED GAMING TRIBES ON HOW
TO DEAL WITH THE EXCESSIVE
SURPLUS IN THE SDF, CURRENTLY
EXCEEDING 100 MILLION
$100,000,160 MILLION IN
NON-GENERAL FUND MONIES. THIS
BILL TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE
INTERESTS OF THE RESPECTIVE
PARTIES, AS WELL AS THE FUTURE
SOLVENCY OF THE FUND, WHILE
ALLOWING FOR OVER $80 MILLION IN
SURPLUS TO BE SUSPENDED AND
REFUNDED BACK TO THOSE TRIBES
THAT PAID INTO THE FUND. THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
RESPECTFULLY, I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 203.
ALLEN AYE. ALRP GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ DALLY.
AYE. DODD AYE. OSO. AYE EGGMAN.
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. JONES. AYE LIMÓN. AYE.
MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO AYE. OKOBO. AYE PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE SENATOR
DODD MOVES THE CALL. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM SEVEN. YEAH. FILE ITEM
79. SENATOR DODD, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. THE.
SENATE BILL 1524 BY SENATOR
DODD. AN ACT RELATING TO UNFAIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
DODD, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YES,
MR. PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES, SB
1524 IS BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
ADDRESS QUESTIONS AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SURROUNDING SB 478.
SB 1524 WOULD REQUIRE THE CLEAR
AND CONSPICUOUS DISCLOSURE OF
ALL MANDATORY FEES FOR FOOD OR
BEVERAGES SOLD DIRECTLY TO A
CONSUMER IN A RESTAURANT, BAR,
FOOD, CONCESSION CATERER,
GROCERY STORE, OR BY A GROCERY
DELIVERY SERVICE. THIS CLEARS
THIS CLEAR AND UPFRONT
DISCLOSURE OF ANY FEE AND A
DESCRIPTION OF ITS PURPOSE WOULD
BE REQUIRED ON ALL
ADVERTISEMENTS, MENUS, AND OTHER
DISPLAYS THAT CONTAIN THE PRICE
OF A FOOD OR BEVERAGE ITEM. SB
1524 UPHOLDS THE PRINCIPLE OF
PROVIDING CONSUMERS WITH UPFRONT
PRICING TRANSPARENCY WITHOUT
INADVERTENTLY HARMING FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS OR SMALL
BUSINESSES. THIS MEASURES HAD A
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 79.
ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLI AYE. DODD
AYE. TERRAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
AYE. OTERO AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE NEUMANN
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NEELO. AYE
OKUBO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE SENATOR DODD MOVES THE
CALL.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS, I KNOW WE'VE
HAD A LOT OF ACTIVITY MOVING
BACK AND FORTH ON THE AGENDA
TODAY, AND WE'RE GOING TO JUST
ASK FOR YOUR PATIENCE. NOW.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
FILE ORDER, AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NOW BACK TO MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS
FROM COMMITTEES WOULD BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON RULES. FILE
ITEM 77 SB 739 PURSUANT I'M
SORRY TO SENATE 29.10 D. AND
AFTER WE FINISH OUR ACTIVITY
HERE, WE'RE GOING TO BREAK FOR
LUNCH AND THEN TAKE UP THE
REMAINING BILLS FOR THE DAY. SO
SENATOR MAJORITY LEADER GONZALEZ
, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I MOVE THE ADOPTION OF
AMENDMENTS AS APPROVED BY SENATE
LEADERSHIP THAT CROSSED THE DESK
ON FRIDAY THROUGH SUNDAY, JUNE
28TH THROUGH THE 30TH, 2024.
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED
AND PUBLISHED. MOTION TO AMEND
SENATOR JONES. MR. PRESIDENT,
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A PARLIAMENTARY
INQUIRY. PLEASE STATE YOUR
INQUIRY. DOES THE DESK OR CAN
THE MOTION MAKER GIVE US A LIST
OF THOSE BILLS THAT WE EXPECT TO
BE AMENDED OVER THE WEEKEND? WE
HAVE NO ANSWER FOR THAT AT THIS
TIME. OKAY. SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT I CLARIFY FOR THE
BODY THAT WE ARE MAKING A MOTION
TO AMEND BILLS, THAT WE HAVE AN
UNKNOWN LIST OF, AND UNKNOWN
AMENDMENTS. IS THAT CORRECT?
THAT IS, THAT IS CORRECT. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I WOULD ASK
FOR A NO VOTE ON THIS MOTION.
AND MR. PRESIDENT, IF I MAY,
EVERYONE USUALLY KNOWS DURING
THE BREAK ALL MEMBERS ARE
NOTIFIED OF THE BILLS PRIOR TO
DURING THIS TIME. OKAY. THANK
YOU. SENATOR GONZALEZ IS ASKING
FOR AYE VOTES. SENATOR JONES IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ALVARADO, GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI NÓ. DODD. AYE
BARROSO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO AYE. JONES NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MEN. AYE NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO OKOBO. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. AYE MENGIBAR. AYE WAHAB.
EYES 31 NOES EIGHT. MOTION TO
AMEND IS ADOPTED. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I MOVE JOINT
RULE 62 Ã TO BE WAIVED FOR THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO MEET AND
HEAR AB 247 ON MONDAY, JULY 1ST,
2024 WITH FOUR DAYS NOTICE
WITHOUT FOUR DAYS NOTICE IN THE
DAILY FILE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
JONES. MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU.
I WOULD MOVE THAT THE PRIOR ROLE
BE SUBSTITUTED FOR THIS ROLL
CALL. OKAY THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. AYES 31 NOS EIGHT
JOINT RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I MOVE AB
247 TO BE GIVEN A SECOND READING
UPON BEING REPORTED BY THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
ORDERED TO THIRD READING.
SENATOR DALLI. OH, I'M SORRY,
SENATOR JONES. SORRY, SENATOR
DALLI TRY TO CUT IN FRONT OF ME
THERE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I WOULD ALSO MOVE THAT THE PRIOR
ROLL CALL BE SUBSTITUTED FOR
THIS MOTION AS WELL. WE'LL DO
AYES 31, NOES EIGHT. MOTION
CARRIES. SENATOR DALLI THANK YOU
MR. PRESIDENT. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD I REQUEST
THAT FILE ITEM 158 SB 2272276 BE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS, THE DESK WILL NOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LIMÓN. THANK
YOU. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS, I WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
ITEMS AB 3121 FILE ITEM 248 AB
2574 FILE ITEM 239 AND AB 2680
FILE ITEM 242 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THANK YOU. THE DESK
WILL NOTE SENATOR SKINNER. YES,
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, I
AM ASKING THAT WE PULL AB 440.
IT'S A FILE ITEM 814 FROM THE
SENATE'S INACTIVE FILE. THANK
YOU. THE DESK WILL NOTE, SENATOR
LAIRD, AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
233. ASSEMBLY BILL 2176 FROM THE
CONSENT FILE AND ALSO AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM 832. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1113 FROM THE INACTIVE FILE
. THANK YOU. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. PLEASE REMOVE FILE
NUMBER 226 AB 1785 FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR. THANK YOU. THE DESK
WILL NOTE SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU. MR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
250. AB 3276 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THANK YOU. JUST WILL
NOTE, SENATOR RUBIO. MR. THANK
YOU. MR. PRESIDENT. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, I WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST FILE ITEM 228 AB
1906 FROM MR. GIBSON BE REMOVED
FROM CONSENT FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE DESK WILL
NOTE SENATOR NEWMAN, THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. PLEASE REMOVE AB
1983 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN SO THE AUTHOR CAN
MAKE AMENDMENTS FROM CONSENT.
SORRY. THANK YOU. DECIMAL NOTE.
SENATOR. SENATOR ALVARADO GILL.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM 152. ASSEMBLY
BILL, 1954 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. THE DESK
WILL NOTE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO REMOVE ITEMS. SENATOR
BECKER. YES, I'D LIKE TO MOVE AB
REQUEST TO MOVE AB FOUR 3437 BY
JACKSON TO THE INACTIVE FILE AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU. THE DESK WILL NOTE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO REMOVE
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO THE CONSIDERATION OF A
DAILY FILE. WE'RE MOVING TO
SECOND READING FILE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 159 WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION 18.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2645, WITH
AMENDMENTS 2503, WITH AMENDMENTS
2697, WITH AMENDMENTS 3179, WITH
AMENDMENTS 2583, WITH AMENDMENTS
. SECOND READING FILE IS DEEMED
READ NOW. MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR GROVE,
SHE'S PREPARED. WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS. FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM 69.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, FILE ITEM
69 IS A CONFIRMATION OF SHERIFF
INGRID BRAUN AND SHERIFF SHANNON
MOON FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING, MONO
COUNTY SHERIFF BRAUN IS THE
FIRST APPOINTED TO THE POST IN
2020, AND NEVADA COUNTY SHERIFF
MOON IS NEW TO THE COMMISSION.
THESE ARE TWO INCREDIBLE
APPOINTMENTS. WOMEN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEADERSHIP THAT ARE
STRATEGIC OUT OF THE BOX
THINKERS WANT TO MAKE SURE THEIR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE AND THE
JUST MAKE SURE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS TRAINED TO DEAL
WITH OUR COMMUNITIES. AND I
CAN'T EVEN SPEAK, THERE'S SO
MANY GOOD THINGS TO SAY ABOUT
THEM. AND I KNOW WE'RE ON A TIME
SCHEDULE, BUT I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT THESE ARE TWO INCREDIBLE
CONFIRMATIONS THAT WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY SUPPORT TODAY. THEY
WERE APPROVED ON THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON JUNE 19TH, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR DALY,
ON THE APPOINTMENT, I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO ALSO RISE AND RECOMMEND
THAT WE APPROVE, COMMISSIONER
MOON. SHERIFF MOON, SHE'S
AWESOME. SHE REPRESENTS NEVADA
COUNTY. SHE DID MY DISTRICT. SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. HEARING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENT. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I,
ALVARADO. AYE. ARCHULETA. I
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. I BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER I BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ I
DALY. AYE DODD. AYE. DORADO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MAGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR I. MIN. AYE NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NEELO. AYE
ATROPOS. AYE. PODIUM AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE
WILK. AYE SENATOR GROVE MOVES
THE CALL. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
70, SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES FILE
ITEM 70 IS A CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR ALEXANDER. SHERIFFS TO
THE APPOINTMENT OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR DISTRICT
BOARD. HE'S A PHYSICIAN IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, CALIFORNIA.
FACILITY FACULTY MEDICAL GROUP
AND A CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT UC
SAN FRANCISCO. HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON A50
VOTE. JUNE 19TH, RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENT. HEARING? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA I ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS I BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR
I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
NEELO. AYE. AYE B¢O AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE.
WILK. AYE. SKINNER. AYE SENATOR
GROVE MOVES THE CALL. NEXT UP.
FOUL. ITEM 72. SENATOR, I THINK
YOU DID IT, SENATOR GROVE. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES,
FILE ITEM 72 IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF THE FOLLOWING APPOINTMENTS.
KEN TANG AND KAREN YAMATO FOR
THE REAPPOINTMENT OF THE STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT BOARD.
MAGGIE HALLERMAN AND KATIE
HAWKINS FOR THE BOATING AND
WATERWAYS COMMISSION. SANDRA
MATTESON, MONTE MONTES, ONE MORE
TIME. MONTE MONTE SMOOTH,
SMOOTH. OH, YES. SANDRA
MONTESANTO AND KATE MULLIN FOR
THE CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION.
DOCTOR FONG LULOFF FOR THE
COMMISSION OF TEACHERS
CREDENTIALING AND CHRISTINA
JERRAM FOR THE STATE PARK AND
WATER RECREATION COMMISSION.
THESE APPOINT. OH, LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ONE MORE. THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
ROYAL COMMISSION ON COMMITTEE ON
JUNE 19TH ON A50 VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR GRACE
ON THE NAMES. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENTS. HEARING.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 72.
ALAN I. ALVARADO. GILL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEAR I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD BARRASSO I DODD I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROVE. I
HURTADO I JONES, I LAIRD I LIMÓN
I MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN, I NGUYEN NEELO. OKOBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I SMILED
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
WIENER I WILK I NGUYEN I NEELY I
SENATOR GROVE MOVES THE CALL.
NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO TAKE YOUR CONVERSATION UP
TO FLOOR OR RETURN TO YOUR DESK.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORIES RIGHT NOW. FIRST UP,
WE HAVE SENATOR BLAKE SPEER.
THANK YOU, PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN THE SENATE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN HONOR OF JAMES
JIM HUBBLE, AN EXTRAORDINARY
ARTIST RECOGNIZED
INTERNATIONALLY FOR HIS
IMAGINATIVE STYLE OF ART AND
ARCHITECTURE AND HIS PACIFIC RIM
PEACE PARKS. JIM PASSED AWAY IN
CHULA VISTA ON MAY 17, 2024, AT
THE AGE OF 92, SURROUNDED BY HIS
WIFE, ANNE AND HIS SONS TORI,
DREW, LAUREN AND BRENNAN. BORN
IN THE VILLAGE OF MINEOLA ON
LONG ISLAND, NEW YORK, IN 1931,
YOUNG JAMES WAS LIKELY MORE
INFLUENCED BY HIS EXPOSURE TO
THE THREE ART GALLERIES THAT HIS
ART OWNED THAN BY SITTING IN A
CLASSROOM AFTER HIGH SCHOOL, HE
MET QUENTIN KEYNES, THE GRANDSON
OF CHARLES DARWIN. TOGETHER,
THEY EMBARKED ON A YEAR LONG
ADVENTURE, VISITING GREAT WORKS
OF ART IN EUROPE AND STUDYING
TRIBAL CULTURES IN AFRICA. AS A
YOUNG MAN, HE MOVED TO SAN
DIEGO, WHERE HE WOULD LIVE, WORK
AND LEAVE HIS MARK ON THE WORLD.
IN 1958, HE MARRIED ANNE STEWART
AND BUILT A ONE ROOM CABIN ON
LAND. THEY PURCHASED IN SANTA
ISABEL IN THE COUNTY'S RURAL
BACK COUNTRY. EVENTUALLY, THEIR
HOME WOULD GROW INTO AN
INTERNATIONALLY RENOWNED CENTER
OF ART AND CREATIVITY. THE 14
HOBBIT LIKE RESIDENCES, STUDIOS,
AND GALLERIES FOLLOW THE NATURAL
CONTOURS OF THE LAND,
INCORPORATING HUGE BOULDERS AND
FEATURING SWOOPING ROOFS,
STREAMING MOSAICS AND SUNLIT
STAINED GLASS. TODAY, THEIR
BELOVED HOME IS CALLED ELLEN
LYLE. AFTER THE FOUNDATION THAT
ANNE AND JIM STARTED IN 1983 TO
BRING ART TO THE MASSES. IT IS A
HEBREW PHRASE MEANING TREE THAT
IS A GIFT FROM GOD. VISITORS
FROM AROUND THE WORLD ARRIVE AT
ELLEN LYLE IN SEARCH OF
INSPIRATION AND A CONNECTION
WITH HUBBLE'S SEAMLESS FUSION OF
ART, CULTURE, AND NATURE. HUBBLE
HAD HIS FIRST SOLO EXHIBITION AT
THE CAPRI THEATER IN SAN DIEGO
IN 1956. HIS CREATIVE USE OF
RESINS, PLASTICS, WELDED METAL
AND OTHER NEW MATERIALS,
COMBINED WITH HIS EXPERIMENTAL
STYLE ATTRACTED A GREAT DEAL OF
ATTENTION. HUBBLE INSPIRED AN
ARTISTIC MOVEMENT THAT
FLOURISHED IN SAN DIEGO AND
BEYOND, WORKING WITH HIS STUDIO
OF ARTISANS, HUBBLE CREATED
HUNDREDS OF WORKS THAT WERE
INSTALLED IN HOMES, SCHOOLS,
GARDENS, PAVILIONS, NATURE
CENTERS, CHURCHES, PALACES,
MONASTERIES AND MUSEUMS
WORLDWIDE. HE MAY BE BEST KNOWN
FOR TWO PROJECTS HIS ENCHANTING
SEA RANCH CHAPEL ON THE RUGGED
SONOMA COAST IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, WHOSE EXTERIOR
RESEMBLES AN ELF'S POINTY CAP,
GIVES WAY TO AN INTIMATE
SANCTUARY THAT MARRIES STONE,
WOOD AND GLASS WITH THE
WINDSWEPT SURROUNDINGS. THE AND
THE SECOND IS THE DOORS OF ABU
DHABI ARE 18 EXQUISITELY CARVED
DOORS INFUSED WITH JEWEL TONED
GLASS AND DRAMATIC LIGHT DESIGNS
THAT ADORN A PALACE IN THE
UNITED ARAB EMIRATES. JIM'S
VISION FOR WORLD PEACE AND THE
NATURE THAT NURTURES US ALL CAME
TO FRUITION THROUGH HIS MASTER
WORK, THE PACIFIC RIM PARK
PROJECT. FROM 1994 TO 2018, HE
DESIGNED, SUPERVISED AND WORKED
ON A SERIES OF EIGHT SEASIDE
PARKS WITH LOCAL VOLUNTEERS FROM
THE PEARL OF THE PACIFIC PARK ON
SHELTER ISLAND IN SAN DIEGO TO
VLADIVOSTOK, RUSSIA, AND PUERTO
PRINCESA IN THE PHILIPPINES. ART
AND NATURE COEXIST IN THESE
SANCTUARIES THAT FEATURE ORBS
THAT CONNECT LIKE A STRING OF
PEARLS AROUND THE PACIFIC TO
FOSTER INTERNATIONAL PEACE. I
HAVE VISITED JIM'S PROPERTIES
AND WAS VERY IMPRESSED BY THESE
STRUCTURES. THEY THEY ARE TRULY
REMARKABLE. JIM LEFT US MORE
THAN ART AND BUILDINGS. THOSE
WHO KNEW HIM BEST WILL CHERISH
HIS KIND, GENEROUS SPIRIT AND
HIS HUMANITY. HE HELPED US TO
UNDERSTAND THAT NATURE INSPIRES
ART AND THAT ART CAN INSPIRE THE
BEST IN US TO BUILD A BETTER AND
MORE COMPASSIONATE WORLD. I WILL
CONCLUDE WITH JIM'S OWN WORDS
THAT BEAUTIFULLY EMBODY HIS
PROFOUND ONENESS WITH NATURE.
UPON DEATH, MY ASHES WILL BE
SCATTERED FROM THE HILLSIDE
CHAPEL OF OUR PROPERTY THAT
FACES SOUTHWEST TOWARD THE SAN
DIEGUITO RIVER. WATER FROM
VULCAN MOUNTAIN FLOWS THROUGH
THIS RIVER ABOUT 55 MILES BEFORE
EMPTYING INTO THE PACIFIC OCEAN.
MY ASHES, CONTAINING MY LIFE'S
ELEMENTS, WILL THUS BE UNITED
WITH THE PACIFIC. FROM THERE
THEY WOULD FOLLOW THE OCEAN
CURRENT TO SOUTH KOREA'S JEJU
ISLAND AND EVENTUALLY END UP AS
GRIST FOR A PEARL IN AN OYSTER
YET UNBORN. THERE, THE CIRCLE OF
ONE'S LIFE IS COMPLETE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO THE THIS
FAMILY. AND WE ASK THAT YOU
BRING THE NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. NEXT
UP IS SENATOR DODD. MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, WARREN
VISHNEVSKY PASSED AWAY ON
FRIDAY, JUNE 7TH, 2024 AT 95
YEARS OLD, WARREN WILL FOREVER
BE REMEMBERED FOR HIS ROLE IN
THE 1976 JUDGMENT OF PARIS, A
COMPETITION THAT PITTED THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS FRENCH WINES AGAINST
NEW EFFORTS FROM CALIFORNIA,
THEN DISREGARDED IN EUROPE AS A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN HILLBILLY
JUICE. IN THE BLIND TASTING
FRENCH WINE EXPERTS JUDGED THE
1973 NAPA VALLEY STAG'S LEAP
WINE CELLARS CABERNET SAUVIGNON
SUPERIOR TO CABERNETS FROM
BORDEAUX, FRANCE, THAT PUT NAPA
AND WITH IT, CALIFORNIA ON THE
NATIONAL STAGE AS A LEADING,
LEADING, PREMIUM WINE GROWING
REGION. HE WAS TRULY A PIONEER
AND FOUNDER OF THE CALIFORNIA
WINE INDUSTRY. IN HIS LATER
YEARS, VERNADSKY BECAME A
PHILANTHROPIST, ENDOWING A
POSITION FOR A CURATOR OF FOOD
AND WINE HISTORY AT THE
SMITHSONIAN INSTITUTION AND
FUNDING A REVISION OF THE
WINKLER INDEX, A GROUNDBREAKING
STUDY ON WINE AND CLIMATE AT UC
DAVIS. HE WAS IN THE 11TH CLASS
OF THE CALIFORNIA HALL OF FAME,
AND HE WAS KNOWN AS A
COMPASSIONATE CONSERVATIONIST,
ADVOCATING FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
CAUSES, AND REMAINED A LIFELONG
SUSTAINABLE FARMER. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN ADJOURNING IN MEMORY OF
WARREN BRONOWSKI. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR MOST, DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES AND ASK THAT YOU
BRING THE NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO SENATE. SENATE THIRD
READING. WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
THAT WILL TAKE UP. FIRST, BEING
FILED, ITEM 88 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO. SHE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 100 BY SENATOR
CABALLERO RELATIVE TO NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN. EQUAL PAY DAY.
SENATOR CABALLERO, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SR 100
WHICH RECOGNIZES A SPECIAL DAY
IN NOVEMBER AS NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN EQUAL PAY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY, THE
FACT REMAINS THAT IN OUR GREAT
STATE, EQUAL PAY FOR NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN IS STILL AN
UPHILL BATTLE. DESPITE THE
ENACTMENT OF THE FEDERAL EQUAL
PAY ACT OF 1963, NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN CONFRONT A SUBSTANTIAL
WAGE GAP, EARNING JUST $0.59 FOR
EVERY DOLLAR EARNED BY THEIR
WHITE MALE COUNTERPARTS. IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE PARITY WITH
WHAT A WHITE, NON-HISPANIC MAN
EARNS BY THE AGE OF 60, NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN OFTEN FIND
THEMSELVES WORKING WELL INTO
THEIR 90S. THIS DISCREPANCY
TRANSLATES TO A STAGGERING LOSS
OF $2,396 PER MONTH, OR $28,747
ANNUALLY, SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTING THE ECONOMIC STABILITY
AND WELL-BEING OF NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN AND THEIR
FAMILIES. NATIVE AMERICAN WOMEN
ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE COVERED BY
A UNION CONTRACT THAN OTHER
WOMEN IN THE STATE, WITH 11.5%
OF ALL WOMEN COVERED BY UNION.
BUT ONLY 5.8% OF NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN. THE LACK OF UNION
REPRESENTATION USUALLY MEANS
LOWER WAGES, LARGER WAGE GAPS,
LESS LABOR PROTECTIONS, AND
REDUCED ACCESS TO BENEFITS SUCH
AS PAID LEAVE, QUALITY HEALTH
CARE, CHILD CARE, AND PENSIONS.
WHEN A WOMAN SUFFERS FROM
FINANCIAL DISPARITY AND
INSTABILITY, THE CHILDREN, THE
FAMILY AND THE COMMUNITY AROUND
THEM SUFFER, AS WELL AS CARRIERS
OF TRADITION AND THE EDUCATORS
OF FUTURE GENERATIONS. THIS
INEQUALITY TRANSLATES TO GENERAL
GENERATIONAL LOSSES THAT CAN
DESTROY HEALTHY FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES, A SLOW DISSOLUTION
OF HERITAGE AND A COMMUNITY
BEGINS TO OCCUR. COLLEAGUES, WE
HAVE TO DO BETTER AS A
LEGISLATURE CHANGES AND AS
GENDER PARITY IS ACHIEVED, WE
NEED TO DO MORE THAN LAMENT,
CALL IT OUT OR MOVE ON. WE NEED
TO PUT OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH
IS AND PARTNER WITH OUR NATIVE
AMERICAN SISTERS TO RECOGNIZE
OPPORTUNITIES TO LIFT THEM UP
AND HELP THEM ACHIEVE THE PAY
EQUITY THEY DESERVE. PLEASE JOIN
ME TODAY IN RECOGNIZING NOVEMBER
30TH, 2024 AS NATIVE AMERICAN
WOMEN EQUAL PAY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
NEED TO ELIMINATE THE GENDER GAP
AND COMMIT TO CHANGE. THANK YOU.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 88. ALLEN I ALVARO TO GO
. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEAR. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZO
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OKOBO AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO.
AYE. SKINNER I SMILED. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. WIENER AYE. WILK AYE.
SENATOR CABALLERO MOVES THE
CALL. NEXT UP IS FINAL ITEM 89.
ONCE AGAIN, SENATOR CABALLERO.
SHE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. THE SENATE RESOLUTION
101 BY SENATOR CABALLERO
RELATIVE TO OVARIAN CANCER
AWARENESS MONTH OF 2024. SENATOR
CABALLERO THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AS WE APPROACH
SEPTEMBER AND IT'S COMING FASTER
THAN YOU THINK, I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
OVARIAN CANCER AWARENESS MONTH.
IT'S CRUCIAL FOR US TO COME
TOGETHER AND RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT OVARIAN CANCER AND ITS
IMPACT ON OUR MOTHERS, SISTERS,
WIVES, AUNTS, COLLEAGUES. DID
YOU KNOW THAT OVARIAN CANCER
RANKS AS THE FIFTH MOST COMMON
CANCER AMONGST WOMEN?
UNFORTUNATELY, IT ALSO HOLDS THE
HIGHEST MORTALITY RATE AMONG ALL
GYNECOLOGICAL CANCERS, MAKING IT
A PRESSING CONCERN FOR WOMEN'S
HEALTH. IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE
AWARE AWARE OF THE RISK FACTORS
ASSOCIATED WITH OVARIAN CANCER,
INCLUDING FAMILY HISTORY, AGE
AND GENETIC MUTATIONS. OVARIAN
CANCER CAN GO FROM EARLY STAGE
TO ADVANCED STAGES WITHIN A
YEAR, AND IT'S HIGHEST IN WOMEN
AGE 55 AND OLDER. PATIENTS WITH
VERY HIGH RISK ARE THOSE THAT
HAVE ENDOMETRIOSIS OR DIABETES.
RECOGNIZING THE SYMPTOMS EARLY
IS KEY, AS THEY OFTEN CAN BE
VAGUE AND EASILY OVERLOOKED.
EARLY DETECTION PLAYS A CRUCIAL
ROLE IN IMPROVING THE OUTCOMES
FOR WOMEN DIAGNOSED WITH OVARIAN
CANCER AND SCREENINGS SUCH AS
COLONOSCOPIES, MAMMOGRAMS, PAP
SMEARS, BLOOD TESTS, AND
ULTRASOUNDS CAN CAN DETECT THE
CANCER EARLY ON. AND AS I
INDICATED, IT'S REALLY CRITICAL
TO CATCH IT EARLY ON. WE MUST
ENSURE THAT WOMEN DIAGNOSED WITH
OVARIAN CANCER RECEIVE THE
SUPPORT AND THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED. ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE, SPECIALIZED
TREATMENT CENTERS, AND SUPPORT
GROUPS ARE ALL ESSENTIAL. I
INVITE EACH OF YOU TO JOIN ME TO
RAISE THE AWARENESS ABOUT
OVARIAN CANCER AND SUPPORT THOSE
AFFECTED BY THE DISEASE. LET'S
RALLY BEHIND INITIATIVES AND
ORGANIZATIONS DEDICATED TO
FUNDING RESEARCH, PROVIDING
SUPPORT SERVICES, AND ADVOCATING
FOR BETTER POLICIES TO EDUCATE,
DETECT, AND ELIMINATE OVARIAN
CANCER. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. FINAL ITEM 89 ALLEN Ã
ALVARADO TO GILL I. ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPUR I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY I DODD I
D'ORAZIO I EGGMAN I GLASER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN I MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR I MEAN I NEWMAN, I
NGUYEN I NIELLO I OCHOA I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
WIENER I WILK I SENATOR
CABALLERO MOVES TO CALL. NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FINAL ITEM 90
SENATORS SATO HE IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 111 BY
SENATOR SATO RELATIVE TO PURPLE
HEART DAY. SENATOR SATO, THANK
YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT. I STAND
TO PRESENT SCR 111. I AM PROUD
TO BRING THIS RESOLUTION BEFORE
YOU TODAY TO DECLARE THIS COMING
AUGUST 7TH. AS RECOGNIZED AS
PURPLE HEART DAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PURPLE HEART IS
A MEDAL GIVEN, NOT AN
ACHIEVEMENT, BUT IN HONOR OF
SACRIFICE. WHILE THE PURPLE
HEART MEDAL WAS ORIGINALLY
CREATED BY OUR FIRST PRESIDENT,
GEORGE WASHINGTON, AND WAS
CREATED TO RECOGNIZE THE BRAVERY
IN COMBAT, TODAY, IT IS USED TO
RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO WERE INJURED
IN SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY BY THE
ACTIONS OF OUR ENEMIES. THIS
SIMPLE PURPLE RIBBON, TRIMMED
WITH WHITE, HOLDING A BRONZE
HEART WITH THE PORTRAIT OF
PRESIDENT WASHINGTON, DENOTES
THE HIGHEST RESPECT AND HONOR WE
AS A COUNTRY CAN BESTOW. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT OVER 1.8 MILLION
SERVICE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
AWARDED THIS MEDAL. MANY
POSTHUMOUSLY. I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE REMEMBER OUR
SERVICE MEMBERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES FOR THEIR SACRIFICES,
FOR WITHOUT THEIR SACRIFICE, WE
COULD NOT ENJOY THE VESTIGES OF
FREEDOM WE HAVE TODAY. IT IS
WITH THOSE THOUGHTS THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND RECOGNIZE AUGUST 7TH AS
PURPLE HEART DAY IN HONOR OF ITS
CREATION IN 1782. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY. YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 90. ALAN I
ALVARADO. GILL I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY I DODD BARRASSO
I EGGMAN I DODD I GLASER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE, GROVE I
HURTADO JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN I
MAGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MIN I
NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NIELLO I OKUBO
I PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I SMILED
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
WIENER I WILK I SENATOR SATO
MOVES TO CALL MEMBERS. NOW WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A QUICK 30 MINUTE
BREAK FOR LUNCH. WE'RE GOING TO
ASK ALL MEMBERS TO STAY IN THE
BUILDING. UPON OUR RETURN, WE
SHOULD HAVE A QUICK AGENDA. WE
ARE WAITING FOR ITEMS TO COME
BACK OVER FROM THE ASSEMBLY. SO
WE'RE TAKING A BREAK FOR 30
MINUTES AND SHOULD BE BACK ON
THE FLOOR AT 1205. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS. RETURN TO THE FLOOR AND
WE WILL FIRST START WITH FILE.
ITEM 204 BY ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA.
AB 2113. SECRETARY PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL. ALRP TIÂU I ATKINS.
CABALLERO. WAHAB I CALLED ABSENT
MEMBERS ON THEIR CALL. THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ONE MORE TIME.
ATKINS CABALLERO. OKAY. AYES 29,
NOES NINE ON THE URGENCY. AYES
29. NOES NINE ON THE ITEM
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 203. SECRETARY, LIFT
TO CALL. CORTEZ I GROVE. WAHAB I
GROVE I. AYES 40 NOES ZERO. ON
THE URGENCY. AYES 40. NÓ ZERO ON
THE MEASURE. MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING MEMBERS TO FILE ITEM 79.
SECRETARY PLEASE LIFT THE CALL.
BRADFORD I, I GLASER. I LIMÓN
WAHAB. I CALLED THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. LIMON. ONE MOMENT.
CLOSE IT OUT, CLOSE IT OUT. I 39
NÓ ZERO. ON THE URGENCY. AYES
39. NO, ZERO. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. NOW WE'RE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 69. APPOINTMENT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
WAHAB I AYES 40 NOES ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. MOVING
ON TO APPOINTMENT FILE ITEM 70,
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NGUYEN I DOLLY BOB, I DALY I
AYES 40 NOES ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 72.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MEMBER WAHAB I AYES 40, NOES
ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 88. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BECKER I, PADILLA I,
WAHAB I AYES 40. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW. MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 89.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE I, WAHAB I AYES 40 NOES
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. NOW OUR
FINAL ITEM ON CALL FILE ITEM 90
SCR 11 111. BARRASSO I, HURTADO
I, WAHAB. I AYES 40. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. REMEMBER
THAT CONCLUDES OUR ITEMS ON CALL
.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING
TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. WE'RE
MOVING NOW TO FILE. ITEM 159.
OH, I'M. YEAH. I'M SORRY. FOLLOW
ON. 260. SENATOR WIENER, ARE YOU
PREPARED? YES, HE IS SECRETARY.
YOU MAY READ. SENATE BILL 159 BY
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW, AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFOR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. SENATOR WIENER,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, SB 159 IS
THE HEALTH OMNIBUS TRAILER BILL.
THIS BILL IMPLEMENTS THE
MEDI-CAL PROVIDER PAYMENT
INCREASES AND INVESTMENT ACT,
WHICH UTILIZES REVENUE FROM THE
TAX ON MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATIONS TO INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR MEDI-CAL
PROVIDERS AND MAKES OTHER
ESSENTIAL PROGRAM IMPROVEMENTS.
THESE INCLUDE INCREASES FOR
PHYSICIANS AND NON-PHYSICIAN
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES SUCH AS
OFFICE VISITS, PREVENTION,
PRIMARY AND SPECIALTY CARE, AND
OBSTETRICS FOR ABORTION SERVICES
AND FAMILY PLANNING FOR
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT PHYSICIANS,
NON SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES DIRECTED PAYMENTS FOR
COMMUNITY CLINICS, AIR AND
GROUND AMBULANCES, COMMUNITY
BASED ADULT SERVICES, CONGREGATE
LIVING, HEALTH FACILITIES,
PEDIATRIC DAY HEALTH CENTERS,
PRIVATE DUTY NURSING, COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS, AND CONTINUOUS
MEDI-CAL COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN
AGES 0 TO 5. IT DELAYS THE
HEALTH CARE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES PROVIDED FOR IN SB 5
TO 5 UNTIL EITHER ONE CASH
RECEIPTS EXCEED BUDGET ESTIMATES
BY AT LEAST 3% IN THE FIRST
QUARTER OF THE STATE FISCAL YEAR
, OR THE MEDI-CAL PROGRAM HAS
MADE NECESSARY PREPARATIONS TO
EXPAND THE HOSPITAL QUALITY
QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE, WHICH
WILL PROVIDE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN NEW REVENUES TO HOSPITALS
THAT THEY CAN USE TO DEFRAY THE
COSTS OF THE NEW MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES. IT IMPLEMENTS PROGRAM
ENHANCEMENTS FOR THE AIDS DRUG
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, EXPANDING
INCOME ELIGIBILITY AND PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE FOR ADAP AND PREP
ASSISTANCE. MOVING TO AN OPEN
FORMULARY, INVESTING IN TGI
WELLNESS AND EQUITY, SUPPORTING
THE HARM REDUCTION
CLEARINGHOUSE. EVALUATING FUTURE
NEEDS IN THE ADAP AND PREP
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS, AND
EXPANDING AVAILABILITY OF
CONDOMS IN EDUCATIONAL SETTINGS.
IT IMPLEMENTS A NEW $115 MILLION
ANNUAL DIRECTED PAYMENT TO
SUPPORT CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE. HEARING.
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I,
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DEL NØ DODD BARRASSO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE NØ HURTADO I JONES. NØ.
LAIRD I LIMON. MCGUIRE I LIMON I
MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I NGUYEN
. NO. NILO. NO OKOBO NO. PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SATO. NO SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK NO, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALVARADO
GILL I DODD I AYES 32 NOES
EIGHT. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 261. SENATOR UMBERG
IS HE AT HIS DESK? STILL.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 261 BY SENATOR UMBERG.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ JESUS
CHRIST, SENATE BILL 92 BY
SENATOR UMBERG. AN ACT RELATING
TO EMPLOYMENT AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. I'M GOING TO GIVE A
MINUTE TO FIND HIS FILE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, SENATOR. MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, THIS
MORNING WE DISCUSSED THE
COMPANION BILL CONCERNING PAGA
REFORM. THIS IS A MONUMENTAL
REFORM THAT CAME ABOUT BECAUSE
OF A COMPROMISE WITH THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS. THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, CONSUMER ATTORNEYS,
THE LABOR FEDERATION AND ALL THE
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS CAME TOGETHER
TO REFORM PAGA. WHAT THIS REFORM
DOES IS PROVIDES A PERIOD, FOR
EXAMPLE, FOR BUSINESSES TO CURE
ANY VIOLATION. IT PROVIDES
RELIEF FOR SMALL BUSINESSES, BUT
IT ALSO PROVIDES AN AVENUE FOR
THOSE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
AGGRIEVED AND HAVE SUFFERED A
LABOR VIOLATION TO ENFORCE AND
SEEK RECOMPENSE FOR THAT. FOR
THAT LABOR VIOLATION, I
CONGRATULATE ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS. THIS IS HOW
GOVERNMENT SHOULD WORK. WITH
THAT, I URGE AN AYE VOTE AND
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
SENATOR ATKINS. MR. PRESIDENT,
THANKS SO MUCH, MEMBERS. I'M
GOING TO BE SO BOLD AS TO SAY
THIS MIGHT BE ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHMENTS WE
ENACT THIS YEAR. I APPLAUD THE
STATE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
THE LABOR FEDERATION IN LEADING
THESE NEGOTIATIONS. THIS
AGREEMENT IS A WIN WIN FOR
EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYERS, WHICH
UNFORTUNATELY IS SOMETHING OF A
RARE OCCURRENCE IN POLITICS.
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE LONG
COMPLAINED ABOUT BEING THE
TARGET OF FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS AND
LITIGATION. THIS AGREEMENT
BROADENS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES TO CORRECT
LABOR LAW VIOLATIONS BEFORE
BEING SUED. WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME CAPPING THE PENALTIES FOR
EMPLOYERS THAT TAKE THESE
PROACTIVE STEPS. WORKERS WILL
BENEFIT BY GAINING GREATER
PERCENTAGE OR PENALTY PROCEEDS
AND WILL BE MADE WHOLE MORE
QUICKLY. THIS OUTCOME IS GOOD
FOR OUR STATE. IT'S GOOD FOR OUR
ECONOMY AND GOOD FOR EMPLOYERS
AND GOOD FOR WORKERS. I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I TOO, RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB 92,
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING HARD TO MAKE SURE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS GOT ACROSS
BOTH HOUSES. AND TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND THE
NEGOTIATION THAT TOOK PLACE WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS. P&G HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM IN THIS STATE SINCE
GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS LEFT OFFICE.
IT'S BEEN AN EXTORTION MECHANISM
BY ATTORNEYS AND ADDITIONAL
TAXES ON BUSINESS, EMPLOYEES
WERE NOT TREATED FAIRLY EVEN IN
THE NEGOTIATION PRACTICES. AND
EVEN IN THE SETTLEMENT
PRACTICES. MILLION DOLLAR
SETTLEMENTS. AND THE EMPLOYEES
WOULD PROBABLY GET FIVE, SIX,
MAYBE $20 EACH IN SOME CASES.
NOT ALL CASES, BUT IN SOME
CASES. SO A LAW THAT WAS
INTENDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EMPLOYEES WERE MADE WHOLE ON BAD
ACTORS FOR EMPLOYEES, EMPLOYERS
FROM EMPLOYERS BECAME A TOOL TO
EXTORT RESOURCES OUT OF
EMPLOYERS. UP TO ABOVE TEN MIL
$10 BILLION OVER THIS TIME. THIS
THAT HAS BEEN ENACTED IS JUST
ANOTHER TAX. IT'S LABELED AS THE
LITIGATION HELLHOLE IN THE
UNITED STATES. FOR THE LAST I
BELIEVE, EIGHT YEARS IN A ROW.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS OF CASES AND THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE PAGA CASES ARE
FOR MINOR INFRACTIONS, LIKE A
WELLS FARGO LOGO VERSUS A WELLS
FARGO ADDRESS, IN YOUR WEEK
ENDING PAY STUBS, IF YOU DIDN'T
HAVE INCLUSIVE DATES THAT WAS A
PENALTY FOR EVERY EMPLOYEE GOING
BACK ONE YEAR TIMES, EVERY PAY
PERIOD. AND EVEN THOUGH THERE
WAS NO HARM TO THE EMPLOYEE, THE
PENALTY PHASE STILL STOOD. AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
LIMITING THE SCOPE OF WHO CAN
FILE A LAWSUIT. I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR NEGOTIATING THE
DEALS TO MAKE SURE THAT
DISCOVERY WAS FAIR. I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR EVEN MAKING
SURE AND MAKING SURE THAT
EMPLOYEES WERE HAVE AN INCREASED
PERCENTAGE, AND IT DOESN'T ALL
GO TO TRIAL LAWYERS, AND SO I
JUST I THINK THIS IS LIKE MY THE
FORMER PRO TEM EMERITUS, THE PRO
TEM EMERITUS SAID THIS IS
MONUMENTAL LEGISLATION. IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED. IT'S BEEN NEEDED TO
BE ADDRESSED FOR SEVERAL YEARS
BECAUSE OF THE ABUSES THAT WILL
BE TAKING PLACE. AND I
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO JUST THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR A STRIKE DATE.
AND THE REASON WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE, LAST WEEK,
678 OR 648 PAGA CASES WERE FILED
AND OVER 1000 WERE FILED ON
MONDAY. JUST TO SEE IF THEY
COULD GET AHEAD OF THIS
LEGISLATION. AND THAT'S JUST NOT
RIGHT. THAT'S MODERN DAY
EXTORTION. ADDITIONAL TAX ON
BUSINESSES, THIS IS GOOD POLICY.
AND I'M PROUD TO BE A COAUTHOR.
ALL RIGHT. ADDITIONAL AUTHOR,
SENATOR BLACKSHEAR. YES. THANK
YOU. I JUST WANTED TO AFFILIATE
MY COMMENTS WITH MY
PREDECESSORS. I SAW THIS AS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS THAT
NEEDED ATTENTION. AND I'M SO
GRATEFUL THAT THE PARTIES WERE
ABLE TO COME TOGETHER AND
MEANINGFULLY NEGOTIATE AND REACH
A COMPROMISE. AS THE AUTHOR
SAID, IT IS GOVERNMENT AT ITS
BEST WHEN WE SEE THAT AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT THAT REALLY
NEEDED TO HAPPEN. AND I'M JUST
VERY GRATEFUL IT DID. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM
HEARING AND SEEING NO MORE
MICROPHONES. SENATOR UMBERG,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? SURE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I ESPECIALLY WANT TO
THANK MY STAFF FOR GETTING ME MY
TALKING POINTS JUST MINUTES
AFTER I WAS CALLED UPON, NUMBER
ONE, NUMBER TWO IS THAT THAT
THIS, AGAIN, IS A TESTAMENT, A
MONUMENT TO THE STAKEHOLDERS,
THE LABOR FEDERATION, THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS, THE
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS, ALL THOSE
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE, ALL THOSE WHO CAME
TOGETHER, WHO RECOGNIZED AN
ISSUE. AND AFTER MONTHS OF
DIFFICULT AND CHALLENGING
NEGOTIATIONS, CAME TO A
COMPROMISE THAT ACCOMPLISHES THE
OBJECTIVES PROTECTING,
PROTECTING EMPLOYEES AT THE SAME
TIME PROVIDING EMPLOYERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CURE ANY
VIOLATIONS. I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 261.
ALAN I. ALVARADO. GIL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY I
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN MAGUIRE I
MENGIBAR I MIN NEWMAN I NGUYEN
MIN I NGUYEN I NILO I OKOBO I
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER SMALL
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS LIMON I
SKINNER. GIVE US A MINUTE. CALL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SKINNER. I AYES 40 NOES ZERO. ON
THE URGENCY I AYES 40. NO, ZERO.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
ITEMS ON CONSENT CALENDAR.
ANYBODY WANTING TO REMOVE ITEMS
OFF THE CONSENT CALENDAR NOW IS
THE TIME. SENATOR MENGIBAR, I
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE PHÐ ITEM
254 FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES WILL NOTE ANY MORE MEMBERS
WISHING TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HEARING
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2759 1849 2114.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
151. ASSEMBLY BILL 1790 2001, 20
1121, 97, 23, 67, 23, 93, 25,
31, 25, 82, 26, OH EIGHT, 26,
89, 27, 67, 28, 35, 28, 41, 29,
79, 32, 58, 32, 32, 86, 32, 87.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
121 169. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 158. ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION TEN. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 204.
SENATE BILL 948 OKAY CONSENT
CALENDAR READ AND SPECIAL
CONSENT. THERE TOGETHER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ALAN I.
ALVARADO. GILL I ARCHULETA I
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER I BLAKE
SPEER I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLEY I DODD I RAZO I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROVE I HURTADO I JONES LAIRD I
LIMÓN. MCGUIRE I MENGIBAR I MEN,
I NEWMAN I NGUYEN I NILO I OCHOA
I PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO I SKINNER I SMILED
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS JONES I LIMÓN
I AYES 40 NOES ZERO ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. AYES 40 NOES
ZERO ON THE SPECIAL CONSENT.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE 29.10,
SEE. THE FOLLOWING BILLS WILL
ARE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES AB FOR 40. SENATOR CIERTO
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE
INACTIVE FILE SCR 114 SR 68 SR
71. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
IF THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE DESK IS
CLEAR, MR. PRESIDENT. FANTASTIC
JOB HERE TODAY. GRATEFUL FOR ALL
THE WORK I WANT TO LOOK AT THE
TIME. IT IS 1228. WE HAD
ORIGINALLY DISCUSSED THAT WE
WOULD BE HERE TILL 3:00 THANKS
TO THE EFFICIENCY. THE HARD WORK
OF THIS BODY. WE ARE GRATEFUL
THAT WE ARE GETTING OUT OF HERE
A COUPLE OF HOURS EARLY. NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER TWO, I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE FLOOR TEAM FOR
ALL OF THEIR FANTASTIC WORK.
MADAM MAJORITY LEADER, TO OUR
ASSISTANT MAJORITY LEADERS AND
TO THE ALL THE WHIPS. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY, JULY 1ST
AT 2 P.M. HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND, MEMBERS. THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL 3:30
P.M, AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE ON MONDAY,
JULY 1ST AT 2 P.M. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS.